So
Und bisschen früher aber es ist ja glaube ich also gestern wäre es glaube ich ja schon 39 gewesen ich kann mir das immer nicht merken
Was genau vor und was zurückstellen heißt und ich kann mir nicht mal merken wann wie vor uns
zurück und was auch immer gestellt wird
Ist auch scheißegal weil nach spätestens zwei drei tagen ist man eh komplett dran gewöhnt am besten ist man ignoriert das einfach und guckt einfach auf die uhr
Gab es da nicht
Gab es da nicht vor vier oder fünf jahren noch vielleicht noch länger her weiß nicht gab es da nicht irgend so eine abstimmung
Ob die zeitumstellung abgeschafft werden soll und da haben irgendwie 80 prozent oder so zumindest zumindest
Die mehrheit weiß nicht mal wie viel es wirklich waren gesagt kein bock mehr auf zeitumstellung
Aber da hat sich nichts getan oder nix
Also kam nie was raus bei jetzt war auch ein bisschen sinnbildlich für zu viel bürokratische scheiße die wir am start haben
moin leute
Eine milliarde bits
Jetzt kommen sie alle
Hockey
Quasi der der poggers im k Occas ja chat gucken zeige euch das jetzt aber
Mitter hat keine sich keine keine verb Ost
dass sie machen ob
let's encrypt da nicht mit macht zumindest was ich euch zeigen wollte ist folgendes guckt mal
hier stream liegt gestern neue bestzeit gerannt und hier da da kann man das bild nicht einfach
doch ihr bild kann man auch mal kommen hier gestern neue bestzeit geflitzt fünf kilometer
knapp 28 minuten ist aber auch echt also das letzte das letzte war irgendwie ich hatte ich
habe sind ich habe es auf twitter reingeschrieben hier kommt man das letzte war genau mein letzte
bestzeit war 8 51 und jetzt 8 28 minuten 6 ich habe keine ahnung seriously wie manche leute
das sind unter 20 minuten rennen
absolut kein plan wie das funktionieren soll man
ich bin komplett dettke haben wir haben wir warum habe ich dettke ihr wisst was ich habe
warum habe ich dettke nicht als als im ort aller das ding mit dem sagt moment ich muss mich muss
kurz dettke hinzufügen kann man das nicht usen doch doch habe ich doch dettke als ich bin komplett
dettke wenn ich das gerade
bin ich habe echt keine ahnung wie das manche leute schaffen unter 20 minuten zu rennen und
wisst ihr was so viel krasser ist der marathon weltrekord der läuft nicht das hier für 42
kilometer der läuft doppelt so schnell für 42 kilometer ziemlich ziemlich genau ziemlich genau
doppelt so schnell der läuft irgendwie 22 50 oder so pro
pro kilometer all das ist komplett stuffen geht runs ich habe keine ahnung wie das überhaupt möglich
sein so wir ja gut ich meine ist halt der unterschied zwischen leute die das die gewisses
talent dafür haben das irgendwie schon seit 100 jahren gefühl machen und halt auch ihr
ganze ganze der typiske also der marathon weltrekord halter pro beides stimmt nicht
ist gab letztens es gab letztens es gab letztens eine neue weltrekord aber sondern nada der ehemalige
Weltrekordhalter. Der ist
ziemlich genauso alt wie ich.
Der ist auch 1984
geboren. Der, ich sag jetzt einfach mal,
der langjährige Marathon-Weltrekordhalter.
Der ist auch 1984 geboren.
Der ist genauso alt wie ich.
Oder fast genauso alt wie ich. Ich glaube, der ist sogar
ein Monat älter als ich.
Und
der rennt das einfach
mit 2,50
2 Minuten 50
pro Kilometer. Über 42 Kilometer.
Alter, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das geht.
Das ist komplett unverständlich
für mich. Also richtig krasse
Dudes, ja.
Der macht das schon. Und der kommt aus
Kenia, wo die wohl richtig krasse
Nachwuchsförderung und sowas für wird.
Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich die einzige Sportart, wo sie das haben.
Aber
da geht es
richtig ab.
Ne, nicht Kenia. Doch Kenia.
Ich glaube, Kenia. Da, wo die ganzen
Runner-Leute herkommen.
Ich glaube, Kenia.
Ja, ich bin 1984.
geboren.
1984 geboren.
In Offenbach.
Nicht Frankfurt.
Offenbach.
Offenbach. Und zwar
ich weiß nicht, wie das Krankenhaus
heißt. Das
in der Richtung vom Hauptbahnhof. Vom Offenbacher
Hauptbahnhof in dem Krankenhaus bin ich geboren.
Ich war aber nie
in Offenbach längere Zeit.
Ich war mal in der Schule in Offenbach. Ganz kurz.
So zwischendurch mal. Aber
ich bin, also ich hab mit Offenbach
nix am Hut gehabt bisher.
Früher hat man ja gesagt, Offenbach
ist noch mehr assi als, gerade
also vor allem wegen dem hohen Ausländeranteil.
Aber Offenbach ist noch mehr assi als
Frankfurt. Mittlerweile
bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob ich das noch
unterschreiben würde.
Frankfurt hat auch irgendwie schon ganz schön abgebaut.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht. Eigentlich hat
Frankfurt nicht abgebaut. Gerade im Hauptbahnhof
ist es im Vergleich zu den
90er und Anfang 2000er Jahren
viel angenehmer.
Also es gibt ja immer noch am Frankfurt,
am Hauptbahnhof massig
Obdachlose, wobei das gar nicht mal so das Ding ist,
sondern die ganzen Drogensüchtigen.
Aber nicht mehr so krass wie früher.
Die haben so ein bisschen vertrieben
in die umliegenden Straßen.
Ja.
Also stimmt. Also meine Garmin-Uhr ist
der Meinung, mein Fitness-Age
ist glaube ich, ist glaube ich 40.
So ja.
Aber wer weiß,
was das Zeug da anzeigt.
Also ich behaupte einfach mal,
dass wenn ich mir die Dudes, die Leute,
die mir da so täglich, wenn ich mal,
also ja, täglich bin ich ja nicht in Frankfurt,
ah, gute Frage, ja, sag ich gleich was zu,
so über den Weg laufen, also Garmin
ist ja der Meinung, ich bin, Moment, ich muss euch
das mal vorlesen, ich bin, ich bin
untere 30% vom Fitness-Level
für mein
Age entsprechend. Ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich in Frankfurt so rumlaufe und mir die Leute
angucke, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass 50% der Leute fitter sind.
Ich bin nicht wirklich fit,
aber Leute, was da rumläuft,
die kommen teilweise,
also da kommt ein Großteil der Leute, schafft es ja kaum
von der U-Bahn irgendwie hoch
zum Willy-Brandt-Platz, ohne dass sie
komplett verausgabt sind. Also ich hab, da hab ich so meine
Zweifel, ob das, vielleicht, vielleicht
50% von dem, was bei Garmin
angemeldet ist und die Leute, die da angemeldet sind,
die bewegen sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen, keine Ahnung.
Wie oft
ich aktuell im Office bin? So im Durchschnitt
einmal die Woche. Ja, geh ich auch mal
von aus. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Also ich bin einmal die Woche aktuell in
Frankfurt, ungefähr so im Durchschnitt,
ich war auch schon zweimal, ich war auch schon
gar keinmal, aber so im Durchschnitt
ungefähr einmal die Woche.
Und ich finde, das ist eigentlich ganz guter,
ganz guter Rhythmus.
Es ist jedes Mal immer übelst
ineffektiv und abfuck nach
Frankfurt zu fahren. Also auf der
einen Seite, man fährt halt mit, wenn du mit der Bahn
fährst, da muss ich mich jetzt nicht,
da muss ich mich jetzt nicht
großartig drüber auslassen,
ihr wisst, ihr wisst, was Sache ist.
Aber
es ist auch arbeitstechnisch
extrem ineffektiv.
Also wenn ich in Frankfurt bin, wenn ich das mal
vergleiche, was ich in Frankfurt geschafft kriege, ist das
fast nix, versus
daheim eigentlich normal.
Mir ist es übrigens
ein Rätsel, wie ich das früher
geschafft habe. Ich verstehe es wirklich, ich kann
es nicht mehr nachvollziehen. Es gibt so ein paar Sachen,
die verstehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Also, das erste ist, wie ich
überhaupt früher, wie wir überhaupt, als wir
damals alle noch ins Büro mussten,
also jetzt halt bei dem alten Arbeitgeber
ist ja egal, wie wir da überhaupt was
auf die Reihe gekriegt haben, das war ja damals schon
genauso ineffektiv wie heute,
aber irgendwie
ging es und
wahrscheinlich hat man sich einfach nur daran gewöhnt, dass es damals
alles viel lahmarschiger
gewesen ist. Zumindest, es gibt so
ein paar Sachen, die verstehe ich halt nicht, wie ich das
geschafft habe. Das erste ist, was ich
absolut nicht verstehe, ist, wie ich es geschafft habe,
fünf Tage die Woche Arbeit zu gehen.
Das gibt bestimmt einige,
die denken sich, was will der jetzt von mir, ist doch ganz
normal und es ist bestimmt auch vieles Gewöhnungssache
dabei, aber ich verstehe es
nicht.
Ich kann es mir nicht mehr vorstellen,
fünf Tage die Woche zu arbeiten.
Und noch schlimmer, ich kann
es mir nicht vorstellen, fünf
Tage die Woche nach
Frankfurt zu fahren.
Du machst ja nix.
Also, guck mal, man muss sich vorstellen,
und was ich mir auch noch mehr vorstellen kann, ich bin
aufgestanden teilweise um 5 Uhr, ich bin
jahrelang, muss man sich mal vorstellen,
jahrelang um 5.45 Uhr
aufgestanden,
nach Frankfurt gefahren,
mit der Bahn, teilweise
mit
dem Bus noch zum
Hauptbahnhof in Hanau,
mit dem Bus, Alter,
wo ich noch in einer alten Wohnung gewohnt habe,
noch nicht hier im Operhaus,
mit dem Bus zum
Hauptbahnhof
und dann das fünf,
fünf Mal die Woche nach
Frankfurt. Und die Bahn war ja damals
schon scheiße. Die war vielleicht
nicht ganz so extrem scheiße wie jetzt.
Anteilmäßig, weil
jetzt ist ja komplett, du kannst ja eigentlich davon
ausgehen, dass es nicht passiert, was auf der,
was, was auf dem Plan steht.
Aber
die war auch schon kacke.
Fünf Mal die Woche nach Frankfurt um
5.45 Uhr. Also, wisst ihr,
ich hab das damals überhaupt nicht realisiert, weil
das für mich halt ganz komplett normal
gewesen ist. Ich bin dann übrigens
morgens auch immer
ins Rechenzentrum gegangen. Damals,
da war es doch schon dunkel, da
konnte man so ein bisschen abchillen,
chillen sagt man ja heute wahrscheinlich.
Was sagt man, wie sagt man heute nochmal zum,
wenn man sich entspricht, keine Ahnung,
da konnte man ins Rechenzentrum noch und ich bin dann
immer durch unsere, in Frankfurt durch
unsere Rechenzentren, die, also da, wo man
easy zu Fuß hingekommen ist, das, das erste
war ja quasi schräg über die Straße schon,
bin ich immer, bin ich immer durch
die Rechenzentren gegangen, relativ
langsam und hab mir alles angeguckt,
ob alles noch okay aussieht und sowas.
Da warst du nochmal über eine Stunde unterwegs,
halt mehr oder weniger im Dunkeln. Ich hab
auch nie Licht angemacht morgens im Rechenzentrum.
Bin da immer im Dunkeln
durchgelaufen. Das war,
das, das war tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen Extended,
Extended Bed-Getime.
Aber gut,
wenn ihr 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden seid
und nach Frankfurt gefahren,
dann bin ich direkt rüber,
Rucksack rüber hingestellt, sonst wie,
rübergegangen.
Da bin ich dann eineinhalb Stunden oder so,
bin ich Rechenzentrum rund gelaufen.
Das war ein bisschen Extended, Extended
Bed-Getime. Aber trotzdem,
ich versteh's nicht. Bus und Bahn
fünf Tage die Woche und wisst ihr, was ich
mich da am meisten frage ist?
Warum, also wie hab ich überhaupt noch
zusätzlich Sachen auf die Reihe gekriegt?
Ich, ich mein,
ich arbeite jetzt vier Tage
und mach hauptsächlich
Homeoffice. Und ich hab jetzt schon den
Eindruck, irgendwie
ich, ich krieg nix, nix auf die
Reihe mehr so.
Und,
also so drumherum, großartig, ja.
Und damals
bin ich fünf Tage die Woche nach Frankfurt
gefahren.
Nicht vier Tage, fünf Tage.
Und hab's irgendwie geschafft,
mit dem Fabian
stundenlang
Kot zu
grinden und
anzufangen Youtube-Videos
zu machen.
Ich weiß noch, ich bin teilweise heim
gekommen mittags. Also was heißt mittags?
Bin ich dann da zurück gefahren?
16 Uhr,
16 Uhr 26 oder so bin ich glaub ich
gefahren mit dem Zug.
Ich hab mir dann, ich bin dann heimgekommen,
hab die Xbox angemacht,
hab drei, vier Runden gespielt,
hatte irgendein Gameplay, hab was drüber gelabert,
hab's hochgeladen. Dann war's irgendwie 18.30,
19 Uhr oder so.
Damals noch 720p,
30 FPS, scheiß Bitrate,
weil nur DSL 3000
zum Upload. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich das alles
auf die Reihe gekriegt hab.
Komplett, komplett unverständlich,
Alter. Keine Ahnung,
wie das funktioniert hat.
Ja, ja, naja, ne,
Fahrrad ins Office fahren ist tatsächlich
nicht so, nicht so gut. Man schwitzt ja da
schon so ein bisschen.
Ich werd zurückfahren mit dem Fahrrad.
Oder auch im Winter, also wenn ich, wenn ich
denn wieder ein Fahrrad habe,
weil ihr wisst ja, meins ist
ja, bisschen in Mitleidenschaft
gezogen, obwohl das erst knapp über einen Monat
alt ist. Ich werd
das Fahrrad einfach morgens
im Zug mitnehmen
und mittags, mittags heimfahren.
Ich bin die Strecke schon mal gefahren,
also es sind ungefähr,
wenn man den angenehmen Weg
fährt, also immer nur am Main
lang, der ist zwar ein bisschen länger
als, als halb durch Offenbach durch,
aber insgesamt deutlich angenehmer.
Das ist der Main, äh, wie heißt
das Ding? Ich glaub, ich glaub, heißt einfach
einfach Main, Mainradweg. Da geht der
irgendwie von Mainz bis
äh, an der Schaffenburg vorbei
bis, bis irgendwie sonst wo.
Halt ganz, ganze Strecke am Main.
Und das
sind 27 Kilometer hin und 27 Kilometer
zurück. Umgef, ungefähr.
Das bin ich auch
letztens, wartet
mal, das bin ich auch letztens
gefahren, hin und zurück, aber
an einem Stück, also irgendwie 74,
äh, 54 Kilometer.
Und das ging tatsächlich
ganz gut. Ja, hier.
Guckt, hier sieht mans.
Hier bin ich nach Frankfurt
gefahren. Ja.
Da, da ging mein Fahrrad noch.
Ja. Hier bin ich nach
Frankfurt gefahren und
das, das hat gedauert
insgesamt zweieinhalb Stunden.
Zweieinhalb Stunden, aber du
konntest da auch teilweise überhaupt nicht richtig fahren,
weil gerade so die letzten, das letzte Drittel
ist halt extrem viel los in Frankfurt, auch wenn
du da durchfährst, runter, runter an Main.
Aber es geht, es geht tatsächlich ganz gut.
Ja, das war tatsächlich auch
das längste, was ich gefahren bin.
Also wir haben in Frankfurt gibt es, es gibt
ein paar Fahrg-, paar ganz gute Fahrradwege
zur Straße in Frankfurt. Leider nix von Hanau
nach Frankfurt. Es gibt seit
Jahren Planungen, Moment,
Hanau, Frankfurt,
Fahrrad, Schnell,
Schnellweg.
Du findest im Prinzip
nur noch so Meldungen. Das ist,
das ist, das ist wieder ohne Scheiß
ein unglaublicher
bürokratischer Ack, so einen Scheiß
Fahrradweg zu bauen, Mann.
Da könnte ich mich wieder, also wenn ich davon
habe, könnte ich mich wieder richtig drüber aufregen, weil
man darf nicht vergessen,
in der Zeit,
wo die Brau-, also die wollen, nochmal kurz,
Kurzzusammenfassung ist, die wollen zwei
zwei relativ gerade
durchgehende Fahrradwege bauen.
Von Hanau nach Frankfurt. Einmal südlich
von Main, einmal nördlich von Main.
Oder
westlich von Main, keine Ahnung. Also einmal
einmal auf meiner Seite und einmal auf
der anderen Seite von Main. So viel, ja.
So.
Und
so. Und
jetzt ist das Ding, jetzt ist
das Ding, beide, beide
dieser, dieser Wege kommen
nicht voran.
Und lokal
wird das hier immer verkauft, als super
krassen Fortschritt. Das letzte, was
ich von diesem Radweg gehört habe, ist,
dass jetzt eine Machbarkeit,
eine neue Machbarkeitsstudie
angefertigt wurde.
Und wenn du so einen Scheiß hörst, da weißt du schon,
okay, das wird nix.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist
der Fahrradweg 5 oder so, hier,
hier, hier, genau,
ne, 8, ne,
hier, genau,
also, 7
und 8 ist das, nördlich von Main
und südlich von Main.
Und das coole ist, also aktuell,
aktuell musst du halt so fahren,
im Endeffekt.
Wenn du nach Frankfurt willst,
so. Das hier ist halt, ihr seht
halt, du sparst dir halt, hier ist
ja schon der Mainradweg, du sparst dir
halt diesen Schlenker. Das sind
insgesamt wahrscheinlich mal gut und gern
so 8, 9 Kilometer oder so,
die, die dir da insgesamt sparst. Also,
sagen wir mal so, es sind anstatt 27, sind's halt
noch 20.
Und der hier oben, je nachdem,
wie man, ist sogar noch ein bisschen schneller.
Je nachdem, wo man hin muss in Frankfurt.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich trotzdem den hier unten
fahren, weil ich muss Willy-Brandt-Platz und so.
So, und die kriegen es einfach nicht
geschissen. Guck hier,
guck hier, im Februar,
du musst dich mal überlegen, im Februar
wurde eine Absichtserklärung unterschrieben,
um eine
Machbarkeitsstudie zu erstellen.
Diese Studie wurde am
20. September 2019
veröffentlicht. Anschließend
übernimmt der Regionale Verband
das Vorhaben umzusetzen. Jedoch stieß
die teilweise auf Vorbehalt,
hierzu wird im Spätsommer
eine weitere
Machbarkeitsstudie vergeben. Alter!
Das ist
so bürokratie-
Shit alles, Mann!
Wilder Igel, danke für den
Zap. Das ist so eine
krasse, dämliche Bürokratie-
Scheiße, Mann! Da könnte ich mich drüber
aufregen. Oh Mann!
Das ist so schlecht, Alter!
Man darf's nicht vergessen,
man darf's nicht vergessen, in China,
ja, haben die ein komplett neues
Viertel inklusive, inklusive
Häuser gebaut in
zwei Jahren. Gut, ich mein, wer
weiß, wie viele Arbeiter in
irgendeinem Fundament einbetoniert sind,
weil sie zufällig reingefallen sind und
dann kriegt die Familie einen Brief, dass er irgendwie
heldenhaft dem Vaterland
gedient hat oder sowas, keine Ahnung, wie das in China
abgeht, aber wie wär's denn, wie wär's denn
mit einem Zwischen-, wie wär's denn so ein
Zwischending, wie wär's denn so ein Zwischending, ja?
Also quasi nicht in einem Jahr
fertig, dafür zehn Arbeiter
verschüttet und wie, und
vielleicht auch nicht zehn Jahre für jeden
Scheiß brauchen. Wie wär's denn so
beispielsweise mit Projekten in
fünf Jahren durchkriegen,
in ganz guter Qualität und ohne,
dass Leute dabei sterben. Das müsste
doch möglich sein, oder?
Aber nein, das ist nicht
möglich. Seligenstadt
Frankfurter Flughafen, gibt's den
schon? Ach ne, ne, ne, Moment, ach
Leute, ich vergaß, 2020
wurde eine Machbarkeitsstudie durchgeführt,
natürlich, was sonst?
Wurde da überhaupt schon irgendwas
gebaut, außer Machbarkeitsstudie?
Machbarkeitsstudie?
Okay, okay, die Machbarkeitsstudie
wurde 2023 auf
Basis dieser Studie
bereiten die
beteiligten Partner kommunal, okay,
das dauert bis fucking 2040
bis dieser Weg da ist, man!
Das kann's doch echt nicht sein!
Guck mal, eine Onlineveranstaltung
von 2012,
die sind seit fucking
zwölf Jahren, seit
elf Jahren!
Ist das, kamen die auf die,
die sind vor elf Jahren auf die Idee gekommen
und das krasseste, was
sie bis jetzt geschafft haben, ist eine fucking
Machbarkeitsstudie,
die bis Mitte des Jahres abgeschlossen wurde,
man! Das kann man
sich doch nicht wirklich,
das kann doch echt nicht sein!
Oh, ey, echt
krasser Scheiß, man! Und was
macht der andere?
2016 wurde eine Absichtserklärung und dann
wurde wieder eine Machbarkeit.
Also, ich krieg, ich krieg
Anfälle, wenn ich mir dieses, dieses
bürokratischen Scheiß hier in Deutschland immer
angucken muss, man!
Oh, man, Alter,
Alter, Wahnsinn!
Wie viel
der gekostet hat? Wahrscheinlich mehr, als hätten
sie einfach angefangen zu bauen!
So!
Gibt's, gibt's ein
YouTube-Video von deiner Katze?
Ja, ja, ja, ja!
Es gibt, es gibt sogar ein Video von
meiner Katze, wo du alle, wo, wo, wo's
alle drin zu
sehen gibt, und zwar hab ich
das während Corona gemacht, wo sich so viele
Leute Tiere aus
dem Tierheim geholt haben,
und ich dann meine Bedenken hatte,
seht ihr irgendwo das Video?
Wo ich dann meine Bedenken hatte,
dass die Leute
die wieder
abgeben,
ist schon so lange her,
hier!
Hallo, Leute! Ja!
Hier! Das ist Chico!
Das ist übrigens
eine Katze, kein Kater, warum auch immer
die Chico heißt, man weiß
es nicht so genau,
weil sich die ursprünglichen Besitzer gedacht
haben, Chico, beste, keine Ahnung,
ich weiß es nicht.
Also das ist Chico,
das ist Chico,
das hier ist, das hier ist original
KatzFPS,
hehe!
Ja, die wollt immer hier hinten auf
am Sofa rumgammeln.
Boah,
da hatte ich aber schon viel dickere Finger
noch, oder? Damals.
Wupp, Wuppet Emote brauchen wir
jetzt. Wir haben extra,
wir haben extra Emotes dafür,
Leute.
Wuppet und Wuppet2.
Ja, das ist
die, und dann, dann haben wir
noch, das ist
der Name von dieser Katz ist echt das
Beste.
Die, die wurde, die hieß
Barbie. Wie gesagt, ich hab die Namen
nicht vergeben. Das
kommt immer ausm, immer ausm, also
wo ich die, ich hab die Namen übernommen,
wie die halt, äh,
wie die halt vorher schon hießen.
Und ganz ehrlich,
die ist echt weit davon hinweg,
so die Barbie-Figur zu haben.
Guckst du dir an, ey.
Dicker Chonker.
Ja, und, und das hat die immer,
das hat die immer extrem gerne gemacht.
Die hat, die hat sich
immer, wie ihr hier seht, die hat sich immer so
Eichhörnchen-Videos auf YouTube angeguckt.
Das fand die super spannend, ihr seht's,
ja. Und manchmal, manchmal ist
die sogar hier hoch und hat hinterm Fernseher
geguckt, wo die Eichhörnchen hin sind.
Willi, danke für den Sub.
Guck, die ist ganz, die ist, die ist
ganz begeistert von den Eichhörnchen im Fernseher.
Ja.
Super, super spannend.
Das, wie gesagt, auf so Zeug,
das hat die ganz, konnte den ganzen Tag gucken.
Ich bin, ich bin
teilweise mit der ins Wohnzimmer
und hab mich da hingelegt und hab
Eichhörnchen
mir angeguckt, weil die das so spannend fanden.
Auf dem Fernseher sind die Eichhörnchen
so groß, wie die ganze Katz,
aber das ist egal. Dafür sieht man sie
gut. Ja.
Und da ist nochmal Chico.
Chico im Hemd.
Habt ihr, falls ihr auch Katzen habt, stehen die auch
auf irgendwie vollgeschwitzte Hemden?
Also das fanden alle meine Katzen immer ganz besonders
toll. Ja.
Vollgeschwitzte Hemden
finden die ganz toll.
Guckt's euch an.
Naja. Ja, also.
Gibt sogar ein ganzes Video.
Es gibt noch mehr,
aber hier sind sie alle drei drinne.
Hast du schon mal Olive probiert?
Hä? Nee, warum?
Meinst du, da gehen die auch total drauf
ab, wenn das nach Olive riecht?
Wie ist der Schaden?
Du meinst vom Fahrrad?
Also wahrscheinlich komplett im Arsch.
Ich hatte, also es ist jetzt
ungefähr genau eine Woche her,
dass ich den Unfall
hatte, letzten Samstag.
Mit dem Fahrrad. Und ich war ja
in der Zwischenzeit, kann ich euch ja mal kurz erzählen.
Ich war in der Zwischenzeit beim Anwalt.
Der hat das übernommen. Ich war
bei einem Gutachter, der hat
und ich gehe
davon aus, das Fahrrad ist total im Arsch.
Der hat, der Gutachter hat auch noch Sachen gefunden,
die sind mir gar nicht aufgefallen, so.
Als Nichtkenner, ja. Aber
eigentlich waren die total offensichtlich.
Beispielsweise, dass das
Schaltwerk verbogen ist und verkratzt.
Dass sogar das
Sattel und das Pedal was abgekriegt hat.
So genau habe ich gar nicht geguckt, ja.
Aber der hatte
halt den Blick dafür.
Und wisst ihr, was ich jetzt gemacht habe?
Ich habe das Fahrrad daheim mal versucht
auf einen, äh
auf so einen Smart Trainer
zu stellen. Geht auch, ohne Probleme.
Aber dadurch, dass die Schaltung
gerade ist, kann ich nicht richtig schalten.
Was ich mir jetzt gemacht habe,
ich habe mir ein neues Schaltauge bestellt.
Ich meine, hey, selbst wenn das Fahrrad ausgetauscht wird,
14 Euro für so ein
Schaltauge kann ich mal ausgeben.
In der Hoffnung, dass die Schaltung dann wieder halbwegs gerade ist,
dass ich das Fahrrad wenigstens die nächsten paar Monate
auf dem Heimtrainer ordentlich verwenden kann.
Jetzt ist eh scheiß Wetter,
das ist nicht so schlimm.
Aber es ist halt echt lächerlich, ne.
Du bist als derjenige, der umgefahren wird,
bist du doppelt im Arsch. Du bist einmal im Arsch,
weil du umgefahren wirst,
und weil du Monate drauf warten musst,
bis du ein neues Fahrrad kriegst,
beziehungsweise dir kaufen kannst.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich so machen,
sobald irgendwie das
Gutachten komplett da ist,
und
wir alle davon ausgehen, so nach dem Motto,
dass quasi das Reparieren
übersteigt, denn die Kosten
für ein neues Fahrrad,
dann vielleicht bestelle ich mir dann schon ein neues.
Und
warte halt, bis das Geld...
Das ist halt richtig scheiße, man.
Versicherungs-Crap, Alter.
Ja, du hast ja noch mehr abgekriegt.
Bei mir geht's.
Also wie gesagt, bei mir war es so,
ich bin, also für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben,
ich habe es letztes Mal schon erzählt,
aber ich erzähle es nochmal kurz.
Ich bin umgefahren worden, auf dem Fahrradweg
vor einem Auto, was über den Fahrradweg
drüber wollte, weil...
Also, müsst ihr euch vorstellen, Ausfahrt...
Fahrradweg? Okay.
Ne, machen wir mal anders. Machen wir mal anders, hier.
Fahrradweg.
Ausfahrt.
Gestrichelt. Straße.
Straße.
Okay, Straße.
Wo das Auto
drauf will. Aber hier...
Fahrradweg.
Beste.
Hier Schild,
Vorfahrt achten. Ne.
Vorfahrt achten Schild.
Und Schild
Fahrradweg
Dingsbums.
Von beiden Seiten Schild.
Ja.
Okay.
Hier geht es ein bisschen so rum.
So, und das hier
bin ich.
Hier bin ich lang gefahren.
Ob Fahrradwege rot sind
oder nicht, ist doch vollkommen egal.
Solange da steht, dass es
ein Fahrradweg ist und solange
der ein Vorfahrtsschild hat,
ist es vollkommen wurscht, ob das rot ist.
So.
So, und dann
kommt hier ein Auto.
Hier kommt ein Auto lang gefahren.
Und ist auch ein bisschen
langsamer gefahren hier. So.
Und fährt dann
aber halt schnell weiter und fährt mich um.
So.
An der Stelle hier hat es... Bäm.
Bäm.
So, und
die erste Aussage,
die ich von ihr gehört habe, war
Oh, sie guckt hauptsächlich
nach rechts, weil die kommen immer alle von rechts.
Ja, das dumme ist halt nur, ich bin
nicht von rechts gekommen. Ich war von der anderen Seite.
Trotzdem ist hier alles
klar geregelt, wer hier wie wo
darf und wer nicht.
Tja.
Ich habe übrigens letztens
in einem Video gehört, dass
60% oder so der
Fahrradunfälle auf dem Fahrradweg passieren.
Was aber durchaus sein kann, weil das bestimmt auch
Unfälle zwischen Fahrradfahrern
mit einschließt. Ja.
Da wurde ich halt umgesäbelt. Ich lag dann
hier auf der Motorhaube.
Hier lag ich
auf der Motorhaube.
Bin dann runtergerutscht hier auf den Arsch. So.
Nachdem sie
angehalten hat.
Das Auto hat eine richtig große Delle vorne drinnen
in der Motorhaube.
Ich hatte glücklicherweise nicht so viel
an mir selbst.
Ich hatte, also an der Hüfte
hat es mir weh getan. Hüfte ist noch ein bisschen,
ein bisschen, wenn ich drauf drücke, merke ich
noch ein bisschen.
Abgeschürft hier Oberschenkel und ein bisschen
hier am Arm.
Und
ja, ein bisschen gezogen
im Arm und auch am Finger. Also ich merke
aktuell, hattest du einen Helm auf? Ja,
hatte ich. Aber ich bin glücklicherweise
nicht groß auf den Kopf
aufgeprallt.
Ja, mir hat ein bisschen der Rücken danach weh getan
und sowas. Aber
passt. Hast du die Polizei
gerufen? Ne, ich hab Fotos gemacht.
Ich hab Fotos. Leider hatte ich meine GoPro.
Ich hatte die GoPro an dem Fahrrad dran, aber ich hatte
die GoPro nicht an. Weil du kannst halt mit der
GoPro bloß eineinhalb Stunden aufnehmen mit dem Akku
und die wollte ich später
dann mal anmachen, wenn ich in ein bisschen
schöneren Ecken bin, als
hier direkt an der Straße.
Ja, und bam.
Also wie gesagt, so 95%
ist eigentlich wieder gut.
Hautabschürfungen sind
ein bisschen noch zu sehen und ich merke sie am
Daumen noch ein bisschen und vielleicht
ein bisschen an der Hüfte. Aber es geht.
Körperlich ist fast alles wieder weg.
Mein Fahrrad ist halt im Arsch
und
ich kann jetzt nichts machen, weil
ich warten muss, bis die Versicherung sich da irgendwie
rührt. Und
deswegen habe ich es jetzt auf meinen
Smart Trainer
geschnallt erstmal, das Fahrrad.
Also Hinterrad raus
und dann auf den Trainer drauf.
Box Subscription.
Ich habe Season 6 nicht mal gespielt.
Wie sind denn eigentlich Leute?
Lohnt sich
das überhaupt noch jetzt in Season 6 rein?
Nicht Social Blade. Steam Stats.
Lohnt sich das überhaupt noch?
Hey, ist gar nicht mal so.
Aber ist nicht auch free? Ist nicht sogar free
gerade irgendwie?
Mülli, danke für den Sub.
Heute Nudel, ja. Neue Schaltung ist
nicht teuer. Naja, doch.
Ist es. Also,
das
ist eine elektronische Schaltung
und da kostet, glaube ich, allein der Schaltwerk
hinten 350 Euro.
Oder 250 Euro. Und das gebe ich dafür
nicht mehr aus.
Wenn ich mir eh Neues holen muss.
Ja, jetzt habe ich es ja gerade
erzählt.
Was für einen Smart Trainer hast du? Ich habe einen
Kickr Core.
Die wollten besonders cool sein mit der
Benahmung. Das kommt so noch aus Zeiten
wahrscheinlich, wo es Flickr gab und Twitter
auch Twitter hieß. Nicht Twitter
und X.
Wieso? Was ist bei dir gewesen?
Ist voll für ein Arsch, Mann.
Aha.
Oh shit, Alter. Okay, das ist natürlich eine Nummer härter.
Also, bis an die Scheibe
bin ich, glaube ich zumindest, nicht geflogen.
Ich bin nur vorne auf
der Motorhaube. Das war ein relativ großes
Auto. Auf der
Motorhaube gelandet. Da ist jetzt
richtig krasse Delle drin auf
der Motorhaube, ey.
Richtig.
Die Motorhaube ist wirklich
so, fast schon U-förmig
so ein bisschen, ey.
Gut, ich bin da.
Ich meine, du musst dir ja vorstellen, ich bin
noch ein bisschen
über 90 Kilo
und im Fahrrad da drauf,
das ist schon...
Aber so heftig war es natürlich nicht.
Ja, das habe ich mich auch gefragt.
Keine Ahnung.
Nach eigener
Aussage, weil die Leute ja sonst
nur von rechts kommen oder hauptsächlich von rechts kommen.
Gab es da einen Stress?
Ey, die, die im Auto gesessen
hat, die war, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen fertiger als ich.
Die hat so voll gezittert und so auch schon.
Die war komplett
nervlich durch so. Aber
passt eigentlich, ne. Die hat sich da
recht kooperativ angestellt. Also, an der wird's
nicht liegen. Das dumme ist jetzt nur, dass die
Versicherung wahrscheinlich super lahm ist.
Habe ich letztens auch mal aus...
ausprobiert.
Habe ich... Ich habe das so gemacht.
Ich habe mein Fahrrad, wie gesagt, auf den
Smart Trainer gepackt.
Dann habe ich einen HDMI-Adapter
an mein...
Da habe ich einen HDMI-Adapter
an mein iPhone gepappt.
Und habe ich...
Weil... Ich hätte ja den
PC irgendwie da rüber stellen müssen.
Weil ich wollte es mal im Wohnzimmer
ausprobieren. HDMI-Adapter
ans iPhone gepackt. Swift drauf
installiert. Du hast ja irgendwie 45 Minuten
Trial oder sowas.
Und da
bin ich... Da bin ich da...
25 Kilometer gefahren in
Swift. War halt echt abfuck,
weil die Schaltung von meinem Fahrrad nicht richtig funktioniert,
ja. Der skippt Gänge
und gerade wenn du nach unten
schaltest, skippt der halt einfach mal
zwei... zwei... zwei Räder, zwei
Zahnräder, was von zu leicht
zu viel zu schwer instant geht.
Also, war echt
schwierig zu fahren, ja.
Mit dem Fahrrad. Aber...
Ich... Man hat gesehen,
super... super krass trainiert bin ich
beim besten Willen nicht. Also, ich
bin die 25 Kilometer gefahren auf
Swift. Gut, ich weiß nicht,
was das Fahrrad dazu beiträgt, ja.
Was kaputte Schaltung und schiefes
Fahrrad, wer weiß, wo das alles reibt,
dazu noch beiträgt. Aber ich
hatte im Durchschnitt, glaube ich, 1,8
Watt pro Kilo.
Das ist halt schlecht.
Aber ey, ich meine, ich mache das noch nicht lang.
Tja, das würde mich auch interessieren. Deswegen
habe ich das ja auch einem Anwalt übergeben.
Weil ich keinen Bock habe, mich damit selbst großartig
auseinanderzusetzen.
Echt virtuelles Schalten, das ist
eine mega Idee.
Wie schaltet man dann?
Mit dem Handy, oder wie?
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist eine echt gute Idee.
Weil dann gehe ich einfach auf irgendeinen mittleren
Gang, der noch gut reingeht.
Und... und...
schalte virtuell über Swift.
Das ist eine echt gute Idee.
Was, den Swift-Cock brauche ich
dann? Ja, den
habe ich aber nicht.
F. Also meins hat
3500 Euro gekostet und ist halt auch komplett
im Arsch. Und mal gucken, wann ich
die Kohle wieder sehe.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Werde ich auch erstmal nicht.
Ich habe mir das mit dem OLED anders
überlegt.
Irgendwas war da, warum
ich es doch nicht haben wollte.
Ich habe die gar nicht so zusammengeschrien.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgeplärt, als ich
da auf der Straße gelegen habe.
Was soll der Scheiß? Hier ist
Fahrradweg. Keine Ahnung. Irgendwas in der
Richtung habe ich da rumgeplärt, aber
die war echt fertig mit den Nerven.
Ach so, ich dachte,
es geht einfach so.
Was ist das? Swift-Cock?
Keine Ahnung.
So!
Dann schauen wir uns
doch mal, wie wir das jeden Sonntag machen,
die Weekly-Trends auf Shithub schnell an.
Was da so abgeht.
Ach ja, ich wollte ja noch eines
zu der Zeit sagen.
Wie gesagt, ich bin ja hier eine neue,
für mich persönlich, neue Bestzeit gerannt.
Mit knapp 28 Minuten
für 5 Kilometer, aber
ein bisschen gecheatet ist es,
weil ich musste
pausieren für
20 Sekunden oder so,
weil der Bahnübergang aufgegangen
ist und ich erstmal die ganzen Autos
durchlassen musste. Also ich konnte
so am Anfang
20 Sekunden kurz verschnaufen,
bis es weiter ging. Aber ich glaube,
das hat jetzt nicht so krass viel
ausgemacht.
Und ich bin auch viel zu schnell losgerannt,
das habe ich gemerkt.
Ich bin losgerannt mit 5,
ich habe dann auf die Uhr geguckt,
5 Zehner-Pace und da habe ich irgendwann
festgestellt, aha Max, du kannst nicht mehr.
Und da habe ich ein bisschen langsamer gemacht
und das war auch eine gute Entscheidung.
Sonst hätte ich das nicht durchgehalten.
So, also was ist hier auf Shithub
das Beste? Leute,
hätte ich euch nichts zu dem Bild erklärt,
hätte irgendjemand verstanden, was ich mit diesem Bild
sagen will? Nein, oder?
Was trennt ihr denn auf Shithub?
AI von Nvidia
in C++
in zwei Gründe.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es mich nicht großartig
interessiert. Ich habe einfach genug
von AI
von AI-Themen in letzter Zeit
und umso mehr C++,
umso weniger interessiert es mich.
AI...
Was?
Ich weiß nicht, was es sein soll, aber AI.
Local Airdrop
finde ich eine coole Sache, habe ich mir
letztens schon angeguckt. Also
das Projekt
sieht eigentlich ganz nice aus.
Da kannst du quasi per Airdrop Dateien sharen
zwischen deinem iPhone und deinem PC zum Beispiel,
solange er Bluetooth hat.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
AI, AI, AI,
nee, nicht AI.
Incubator Answer, was?
Was soll das sein?
Ach, das ist ein Stack Over.
Eigentlich eine
coole Sache, oder?
Eigentlich ist das eine coole Sache.
Eigentlich mega
nice.
Sowas bräuchten wir bei
mir auf der Arbeit auch, anstatt 50
Knowledge Base Systeme, wo keiner mehr
durchblickt. Aber bei uns auf der Arbeit
neue Sachen zu etablieren ist ja
eine Lebensaufgabe und da bin ich
nicht berufen für.
Fühl ich mich nicht berufen zu.
Also, wenn man
denkt, die Bürokratie ist schlimm
für den Fahrradweg hier,
die Bürokratie bei mir auf der Arbeit
übertrifft das noch mehr.
Die sind super bürokratisch.
Wanderdingsbums, danke für den Sub.
Oh, was ist das?
The cutest Discord Client
Mod. Okay, Leute, das war's
für uns.
Da können die ganzen Weebs jetzt hier
anrücken. Also, cutest
Discord Client.
Ich sehe schon.
Wo ist der Sbarro, wenn man ihn braucht?
Der Sbarro hat das
bestimmt schon.
Das muss ich mir angucken.
Venkort.
Ah, ja, ja.
Viele Infos darüber gibt's
ja nicht wirklich, oder?
Gibt's da vielleicht ein paar Bilder dazu?
Ich sehe schon hier.
Hypercute
Discord Mod.
Na dann.
Aber das finde ich auch ein ganz cooles Projekt.
Rasiert nicht.
Was?
Performance Tools for Java.
Was? Was sonst?
Written in Rust. Blazingly Fast.
Wo sind die Krustentiere
hier wieder?
Was soll das sein?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was es sein soll überhaupt.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Was ist das überhaupt?
Kann man damit Standalone-JavaScript-Dinger
erstellen, oder?
Es ist Blazingly Fast, weil Written in Rust.
Aber was macht das überhaupt?
Manchmal würde ich mir wünschen, bei irgendwelchen
Projekten, wenn man einfach mal so 2-3
Sätze dazu stehen hätte, was es ist.
Ich meine, The Oxidation
Compiler. Was?
Hier.
Parser, Linter, Formatter, Transpiler,
Minifier, Resolver.
All written in Rust. Okay, und warum?
Warum sollte ich das verwenden?
Ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass der Buildstep
und so irgendwie das große... Naja.
Egal. Weil Written in Rust. Schadet ja nix.
AI.
Ruff.
Ey.
Wie hat jeder Scheiße den Rust rewritten gerade?
Es gibt
sogar mittlerweile
DF rewritten
in Rust wahrscheinlich, denke ich mal.
Ja.
Natürlich.
DF written in Rust. Was sonst?
Ich frage mich, wann sie Rust in Rust
rewiten. Ja, genau.
Was ist das? Irgendwelches
China-Chinesen-Zeug?
Okay.
What the fuck? Ist das das China-Chinesen
Spotify oder sowas?
China-Spotify?
Ich weiß nicht.
Verstehe. Okay, warte.
Google Translate. Wobei, nee.
Das ging doch hier irgendwie.
Englisch.
Äh. Deutsch?
Äh.
Da muss die Zielsprache ausgewählt werden.
Google, Mann.
Diese Webseite ist nicht auf Englisch.
Diese Seite...
Was?
Ist es Chinesisch oder Japanisch?
Keine Ahnung.
Japanisch? Probieren wir das mal.
Okay.
Es scheint Japanisch zu sein.
Eine Basis für Elektron plus
View. Es ist der
Rakuyuki Otoki
Assistent Box Version.
Alles klar. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Das ist bestimmt irgendein
japanischer Musik-Streaming-Service.
Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Ohne es zu wissen.
Kann DeepL
...
Ach nee, Database.
Das ist schon schlimm, oder?
Wenn das erste, woran du bei DB denkst, die Bahn ist und keine Database.
Okay, diese Woche ist nicht sonderlich spannend.
Aber eigentlich ganz cool, wir haben zwei Sachen gefunden, die man sich mal angucken kann.
Nicht, dass da, wenn Quad, ganz wichtig, muss ich nachher unbedingt ausprobieren.
Ich brauche den cutesten Discord überhaupt.
Und das hier finde ich eine richtig coole Sache.
Aber das ist bei mir auf der Arbeit hoffnungslos, sowas einzuführen.
Ja, ja, ja, geht halbwegs wie.
Das meiste ist weg. Leider ist mein Fahrrad im Arsch.
Wie im Arsch habe ich gemerkt, seitdem ich es auf den Heimtrainer hier geschnallt habe,
dass die Schaltung gar nicht mehr richtig geht.
Warum ist Rust so gehypt?
Tja, ich glaube, das hat mehrere Gründe.
Rust ist seit Jahren schon gehypt, darf man nicht vergessen.
Das liegt zum ersten Mal daran, also es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach zu sagen.
Es liegt, glaube ich, einmal an Rust selber.
Und es liegt an dem Kult.
Der um Rust mittlerweile existiert, den es aber gar nicht gegeben hätte, hätte Rust nicht was richtig gemacht.
Also ich denke mal, aus Rust-Sicht hat es schon ein paar ganz coole Sachen, die auch ziemlich, wie sagt man, waren so neu, wie heißt das auf Deutsch, so neu, die das Sachen gemacht haben, die vorher sonst kaum einer gemacht hat.
Und in Kombination innovativ, ja.
Was heißt Novelty denn so?
Neuheit, ja.
Die es halt besonders neu gemacht hat.
Und zwar, Rust ist an sich im Kern eine Unmanaged-Sprache.
Das heißt also, da ist im Hintergrund keine Memory-Garbage-Collection und auch kein automatisches Memory-Management dahinter.
Trotzdem musst du dich so gut wie nie um manuelles Memory-Management kümmern.
Und?
Du kannst dir bei vielen Sachen zur Compile-Zeit schon sicher sein, dass sie so funktionieren werden, wie du es gebaut hast.
Das heißt nicht, dass du nicht Fehler bauen kannst, aber es ist tatsächlich in Rust gar nicht so einfach, kaputte Sachen zu bauen, weil Rust hat relativ viele Compile-Time-Checks, was die Lebenszeit von Variablen, ich versuche es mal ganz grob zu umschreiben, ja.
Also was die Lebenszeit von Variablen, nennen wir es mal.
Ja, nennen wir es mal Objekte angeht.
Also wo in einer kompletten Managed-Sprache das alles getrackt ist, also du kannst ja in einer Managed-Sprache gar nicht so sagen, jetzt hier, lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz ein bisschen Speicher anfordern und dann sagst du, ich geb den einfach nicht frei.
Das passiert im Hintergrund alles für dich.
Bei vielen Sprachen kannst du es trotzdem machen.
Bei Rust ist es so, Rust trackt die theoretisch mögliche Lifetime von...
Sachen, die du angelegt hast und sagt dir, wenn du sie nicht richtig aufräumst, beziehungsweise wenn du sie nicht richtig benutzt, also zum Beispiel, wenn du in Rust eine Variable anlegst, die out of scope geht oder nicht klar ist, welcher Teil des Programms dafür zuständig ist, dass die am Ende aufgeräumt wird, dann lässt es dich schlicht und ergreifend nicht kompilieren.
Das heißt, Rust verbindet quasi so ein bisschen die Geschwindigkeit von...
Mit ein bisschen mehr Memory Safety und Sicherheitsfeatures zu Compile-Sight, dass du dir nicht so leicht in den Fuß schießen kannst und nicht so leicht Sicherheitslücken produzieren kannst.
Das heißt, Rust ist richtig gut für solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel eine CSS-Engine für einen Browser, was übrigens auch der erste Anwendungszweck war, weil das Ganze wurde von Mozilla entwickelt und das sind ja die mit Firefox.
Also für sicherheitskritische Anwendungen, die trotzdem Peak-Performance...
Brauchen, sozusagen.
Dafür ist Rust gut.
Was man mit Rust allerdings sich auch ein bisschen einfängt, und auch das wollen die Rust-Leute zwar nicht wahrhaben, aber meiner Meinung nach ist das so, auch, dass man nicht so hohe Developer-Produktivität in Kauf nimmt.
Ich finde, Rust ist nicht sonderlich produktiv schreibbar, programmierbar und auch nicht sonderlich gut lesbar.
Das kann man aber in Kauf nehmen, wenn man eine Anwendung baut, die eben genau in diesem Bereich sich abspielt.
Du brauchst super krasse Performance, aber das Ganze, ja, so sicher wie möglich noch, was Memory Safety angeht.
Ist natürlich bei vielen Programmen gar nicht notwendig, ja.
Wenn du sagen würdest, nimm mal zum Beispiel Spiele.
Spiele brauchen krasse Performance, aber der Rest ist nicht so wichtig.
Im schlimmsten Fall crasht dir das Game.
Wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise von irgendeiner...
Sandbox im Browser reden, die muss schnell sein, die muss aber auch so sein, dass nicht irgendjemand aus der Sandbox aussprechen kann.
Das heißt, das ist wirklich so ein guter Punkt für Rust.
Und sicherlich wird das besser, umso besser man in Rust wird, was die Developer-Produktivität angeht.
Aber trotzdem ist das, finde ich, so eines mit, dass Rust auch eklig lesbar ist, gerade wenn sich die Leute keine Mühe geben.
Also, Rust hat gefühlt mehr Sonderzeichen als C++ und das heißt schon was.
Teilweise mehr Klammern als Erlang.
So, und dadurch, dass das eben so neuartig war in diesem Ansatz, quasi so sicher wie möglich, aber ohne Performance-Kompromisse,
hat das so einen gewissen Kult aufgebaut um sich, Rust.
Und die sind doch überall aktiv, wo es um Programmiersprachen geht.
Also, sei es auf YouTube oder sei es auf Hacker-News oder auf Reddit, du hast immer, wenn irgendwo irgendwas ist,
so ein paar von der, ja, von der Rust-Taskforce, die da aufploppen und den Leuten erzählen,
oh, mit Rust wäre das nicht passiert und das ist der Grund, warum ich nur noch Rust verwende,
seit drei Jahren nur noch Rust und es gibt keine Probleme mehr.
Ihr habt diese Comments wahrscheinlich auch schon überall gesehen, so.
Und das sind diese zwei Dinge.
Also, einmal macht Rust...
Sachen wirklich neuartig und auch sehr, ja, sehr innovativ für bestimmte Bereiche
und es lohnt sich dann auch, Rust zu verwenden,
aber so dieses Gehype und dieses Kult-Following um Rust tut noch mal sein Übriges dabei.
Und deswegen gibt es, glaube ich, auch so viele Leute, die ihre Programme in Rust schreiben,
die man eigentlich gar nicht bräuchte, ja.
Warum muss ich ein...
DF re-implementen in Rust?
Oder warum muss ich ein...
Ja, keine Ahnung, was gibt's denn sonst noch?
Was sonst noch?
Echo wahrscheinlich.
Leute, passt mal auf.
Echo, Rust, es gibt bestimmt Echo re-implemen...
Ja, ja.
Okay, ja.
Also, das ist, weil's geht.
Das ist, weil's geht.
Und...
Weil es sich einfach gut macht, die Leute schreiben dann immer auf ihre GitHub-Seite so nach dem Motto,
DF re-implemented in Rust.
Blazingly fast.
So.
Und haben dann instant 5000 GitHub-Sterne.
Im Endeffekt habe ich aber immer den Eindruck,
dass dieses re-implemented Zeug in Rust,
erstens irgendwie kaum jemand wirklich dauerhaft benutzt,
und zweitens viele der Projekte auch nach einem halben Jahr,
wenn die Leute keinen Bock mehr auf Rust haben, einfach wieder runtergehen.
Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen, ja.
Aber das Ding ist halt,
die ganzen Standard-Tools müssen nicht re-implemented werden in Rust.
Und ich sag euch auch warum.
Jeder kann sein Zeug re-implementen in Rust, so viel er will und so viel er Bock hat.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Und man lernt auch was dabei.
Das ist wirklich gar kein Ding.
Soll jeder machen, was er will.
Aber das Ding ist halt folgendes.
Warum ich das nicht für sonderlich sinnvoll halte, Standard-Tools zu re-implementen in Rust.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel sowas wie LS.
Jeder auf der Welt, der ein bisschen was mit Linux zu tun hat, weiß,
so grob wie LS funktioniert.
Ja, so nach dem Motto, LS, ja, Zeug auf Listen im Ordner, LS, LA,
das Ganze ein bisschen ausführlicher,
und das Ganze noch human readable und reverse sortiert nach Datum, nach Änderungsdatum so.
Das kann jeder.
Jetzt gibt es zum Beispiel sowas wie EXA,
das ist quasi ein fast LS-kompatible Rust-Re-implementierung,
die aber nicht ganz kompatibel ist.
Und das Ding ist halt folgendes.
Diese Standard-Tools, LS, Z, grep, grep gibt es ja auch re-implemented in Rust,
DF, AWK und so, was es nicht alles gibt,
also das, was man zu 90% in irgendwelchen Shell-Skripts und interaktiv auf der Kommandozeile verwendet,
die gibt es halt schon lange.
Man hat sich daran gewöhnt, wie die Dinger funktionieren.
Und niemand hat auf einem Remote-System die Rust-Implementierung davon installiert.
Es bringt mir überhaupt nichts.
Wenn ich irgendwie einen LS habe, was written in Rust ist,
und super tolle, krasse Features habe,
und ich mich daran gewöhnt habe,
dass ich jetzt, keine Ahnung,
LS minus das machen kann,
und dann kommt was ganz geiles bei raus,
wenn das LS auf einem Remote-System das nicht hat.
Also ich bin der Meinung, man fährt ganz gut,
wenn die Standard-Tools wirklich lokal und remote auch die Standard-Tools sind.
Wir reden hier wirklich von den Basic-Sachen.
CD, LS, grep, Z, AWK, so die Basic-Sachen,
die müssen nicht re-implemented in Rust sein.
Niemand hat auf dem Remote-System die re-implemented Sachen in Rust drauf.
Und wenn man sich daran gewöhnt,
ist es sogar schon ein bisschen nervig,
weil du dann zum Beispiel sagst,
LS minus das da und stellst,
oder was auch immer das sein soll,
Poash, geht nicht.
Ich habe einfach face-rolled auf der Tastatur gerade.
Und deine Rust-Implementierung macht dann was krasses,
wenn du LS minus Poash machst.
Aber die Standard-Implementierung,
die Standard-Implementierung macht nichts.
Und deswegen finde ich,
ist das fast schon ein bisschen kontraproduktiv,
die Basic-Tools in Rust re-written zu verwenden.
Und ich finde auch,
dass genau dort Rust eigentlich nicht seine Stärken hat,
in solchen Tools.
Aber jeder kann ja re-writen und machen,
was er lustig ist.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Drei Monate FISI,
Fachinformatiker, Anwendungsausbildung hinter mir.
Mach mal in drei Wochen COBOL gelernt,
viel mit Groß...
Ja, das ist am Anfang.
Am Anfang ist immer sehr viel,
was auf einen einprasselt,
weil es ja nicht nur die ersten drei Monate sind,
wo du dich jetzt mit der Technik auseinandersetzt,
sondern auch drei Monate ganz viel Neues.
Viele Leute waren vorher noch nie in der IT tätig,
haben noch nie was gearbeitet,
müssen sich erst mal ein bisschen
mit den Leuten auseinandersetzen,
mit den Gegebenheiten in der Firma.
Also die ersten drei Monate dürften wahrscheinlich
mit Abstand des Anstrengens sein.
Danach wird das alles ein bisschen entspannter.
Ab jetzt wird es
eigentlich nur noch entspannter.
Ja, man kann sich Mühe geben,
aber Rust ist halt sehr sonderzeichenlastig.
Ja gut, wenn ich von C++ kommen würde,
würde ich wahrscheinlich auf alles abfahren.
Weil schlechter kann es ja nicht mehr werden.
Kennst du eine gute Seite,
wo man Programmieren lernen kann?
Es gibt jede Menge.
Ja, ich wollte auch gerade sagen,
guck dir YouTube-Tutorials an.
Such dir vor allem erstmal eine Sprache und Technik raus,
mit der du anfangen willst.
Wenn du keine Ahnung hast, oh ne,
ich weiß nicht, das ist,
das ist, das ist,
die sind doch auch schon,
da steht doch auch schon immer,
wenn du HTML-Sachen nachgucken willst,
achso, okay, das ist doch keine Scam-Seite.
Kenn ich nicht.
Also wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast,
mit was du anfangen willst,
dann ist tatsächlich aus meiner Sicht
das Einfachste, installiere Wischel Studio Code
und bastel ein bisschen
mit JavaScript, HTML und CSS rum.
Weil JavaScript ist eine Sprache,
die begleitet dich mehr oder weniger
wahrscheinlich dein ganzes Entwicklerleben
immer mal mehr und mal weniger
und immer mal wieder.
Es sei denn, du wirst irgendwann wirklich Frontend-Entwickler,
weil dir das gut gefällt.
Es ist ein großes,
großes Feld, werden auch viele gesucht
und macht sicherlich auch Bock,
wenn einem das gefällt.
Machen ja sehr viele.
Dann hast du natürlich noch mehr JavaScript.
Aber das, was du gelernt hast,
so die Basics in JavaScript,
bringen dir natürlich auch in jeder anderen Sprache was.
Wenn du gelernt hast,
wie du
irgendwie einen Switch machst,
einen If machst,
eine Array anlegst und sowas.
Klar, das ist immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich pro Sprache,
aber so von den Konzepten her
bringt dir das was.
Und zum Einstieg ist es halt
mit Abstand am einfachsten,
einfach sich Wischel Studio Code zu installieren,
HTML-Seite
zu erstellen
und da ein bisschen JavaScript reinzuhauen.
Und du siehst visuell auch gleich was, was passiert.
Also ich kann dir nur empfehlen,
fang mit JavaScript, HTML und CSS an.
Es sei denn, du hast schon was,
Lukas, hast du denn schon irgendwas im Kopf,
was du machen willst?
Wenn du was Spezielles im Kopf hast,
dann ist es natürlich sinnvoll,
auch damit anzufangen,
was dir da was bringt.
Also wenn du jetzt sagst,
ich würde gerne eine Windows-Desktop-Anwendung erstellen,
ich hoffe nicht, dass es das ist,
aber es gibt ja Leute, die wollen das machen,
dann ist jetzt vielleicht JavaScript, CSS, HTML
Dank Elektron geht das ja
mittlerweile auch.
Wenn Hello World 500 MB RAM
brauchen soll, aber man hat ja heutzutage
genug RAM. Wenn du das machen willst,
würde ich dir was anderes empfehlen.
Wenn du nur Linux
Kommandozeilen-Tools entwickeln möchtest,
dann
ist vielleicht Go nicht verkehrt.
Also
du musst wissen, was du
vorhast. Ansonsten, wenn du es nicht weißt,
dann JavaScript, CSS, HTML
und Text Editor Browser
fertig, los geht's.
Einstiegshürde ist einfach am geringsten.
If-Schleifen
sind prinzipiell am besten.
Ich verwende eigentlich nur noch If-Schleifen.
Wie synchronisierst du verschiedene Settings?
Gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe eine Dot-Files-Repo
auf GitHub, da habe ich aber
nicht meine JetBrains-Settings drinnen.
Ich habe aber auch gar nicht
so viele Sachen in meinen JetBrains IDE
eingestellt und wenn ich mal irgendwo
an einer neuen Kiste bin, stelle ich die 5-6 Sachen
so mal schnell von Hand ein.
Was habe ich in meinen JetBrains IDE
eingestellt? Meine Schriftart,
die Schriftgröße,
ich habe eingestellt, dass
Zeile hoch,
Zeile runter moven,
also Shortcuts, Zeile hoch, Zeile runter moven,
ich weiß gar nicht, was sonst noch.
Farbschema, Farbschema
habe ich eingestellt,
habe ich immer das
überall das
RiderDark, auch hier nicht
Rider, habe ich RiderDark.
Ansonsten bin ich
mir gar nicht so sicher, was ich noch
habe. Achso, äh
Undo, Redo
habe ich Shortcuts
umgelegt, weil manchmal sind die so ganz merkwürdig
platziert.
Aber ansonsten, ich glaube, das war es eigentlich.
Ja, da lässt aber auch
kein Elektron laufen.
Also man hat auf dem Desktop eigentlich mehr oder weniger
genug RAM, auch für 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 Elektron-Anwendungen.
Guck mal, ich meine, guck mal hier.
20G von
63G. Und
ganz ehrlich, von diesen 20G
ist die Hälfte auch nicht belegt.
Sinnig?
Das ist meine 4M. Ein Großteil
davon ist meine 4M, die selbst
24G hat.
Und wenn ich die 4M beende, dann ist
das Memory wahrscheinlich, ja, dann ist
es 12. Und davon ist wahrscheinlich
auch noch nicht mal wirklich richtig viel
in use, sondern ganz viel
so pre, pre,
ja, wie nennt man das so, so allocated
dass es schneller geht.
Also kannst du vergessen. Wahrscheinlich brauche ich
grad irgendwie 6G RAM oder so, die notwendig
wären.
Und das meiste davon
braucht wahrscheinlich mein Browser,
weil ich ein bisschen viele Tabs
auf hab.
Meinung zum neuen Teams? Ich hab's noch nicht verwendet.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir, wer hätte das gedacht? Bei uns dauert
sowas immer 30 Jahre, bis sich das
ändert.
Aber noch Teams Classic.
Es ist lahmes Fuck wie vorher,
aber ganz brauchbar.
Übrigens, ich hab ja die ganze Zeit immer nur Teams gelobt.
Ich hab ja immer
gesagt, Leute, ich versteh dieses
Gehate gegen Teams nicht, guckt euch mal die Alternativen
an. Sowas wie Zoom zum Beispiel
oder noch schlimmer, was man früher hatte, Skype
oder ganz schlimm, WebEx.
Falls irgendjemand Cisco
WebEx mal verwenden musste.
Dagegen ist Teams doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Und ja, ich denke immer noch, dass Teams insgesamt
tatsächlich gar nicht
übel ist. Eine Sache
ist mir jetzt aber aufgefallen, die in den
Teams richtig
kacke ist.
Aber richtig kacke.
Teams ist super
krass closed.
Die haben zwar
eine
wie heißt das? Craft API
oder sowas.
Kannst du machen, wenn deine Firma
die passende Infrastruktur dafür hat.
Dann geht das.
Hab ich aber selbst noch nie
aufgesetzt. Das geht aber.
So und du kannst
es komplett vergessen Teams
irgendwie API
technisch anzusprechen.
Das ist einfach nicht
möglich richtig. Also
wenn du jetzt beispielsweise sagst, hey
ich würde gern
also warum ich mich damit beschäftigt habe ist
also zumindest
wenn ich mir das mal kurz angeguckt habe ist
wir haben bei uns im Teams
haben wir
so eine Funktion
da kann man
festlegen, also mal angenommen
man hat so eine Sammelrufnummer
und man möchte die Sammelrufnummer
umstellen ab 17 Uhr
zum Beispiel auf eine
bestimmte Nummer und das möchte
man abhängig vom Tag
machen halt an denjenigen
der Bereitschaft hat.
So habe ich mir überlegt wäre es nicht cool
wenn man das über die API machen könnte
ganz automatisch. Man guckt einfach
nach wer Bereitschaft hat
und lässt es automatisch umstellen
ab 17 Uhr. Leute keine
Chance. Unmöglich.
Über Teams selbst geht
das. Du kannst in Teams kannst du auf
Settings gehen, auf Sammelrufnummer
und dann irgendwie auf Weiterleiten
so überhaupt kein Problem. Aber über
irgendeine API, über irgendeinen Service
unmöglich.
Geht nicht. Kannst du
komplett vergessen.
Und die Teams API überhaupt so zu nennen
ist schon ein Witz. Du kannst es vergessen.
Was du machen kannst eventuell mit sehr viel
Glück ist, du könntest eine Teams
App entwickeln
die man dann über den Teams App Store installieren kann. Aber
das bringt dir dann auch nichts.
Es ist komplett für den Arsch.
Also so Programmierschnittstellen ist
für Teams komplett Kacke.
Richtig mega scheiße.
Ja. Der Rest ist aber ganz brauchbar.
Ja was du machen kannst ist
du kannst Desktop Automatisierung benutzen.
Klicke jetzt dahin, klicke jetzt
dahin, klicke jetzt dahin.
Also du müsstest zum Beispiel
du müsstest
zum Beispiel dir eine VM installieren
wo immer alles exakt gleich groß ist
und dann kannst du da in Teams klicken.
Ja das würde eventuell vielleicht funktionieren.
Nö.
Könnte man, könnte man vielleicht machen.
Aber ich gehe davon aus
dass die, das ist ja dann
keine offiziellen API Geschichten
das sind ja so inoffizielle
Sachen von Microsoft, dass sich das auch
öfters ändert und du garantiert
allein schon für die Authentifizierung wieder
einen riesen Akt machen musst.
Also ich glaube das ist kein richtig gangbarer
Weg. Du kannst in Teams da
steuern aber nicht irgendwie programmiert
technisch. Das ist halt das Problem.
So jetzt machen wir das hier mal zu.
So was können wir uns denn heute mal anschauen?
Was ist das?
My Deals
Die haben einen Youtube Channel?
Ey weißt du was?
Das ist eine ziemlich
gute Idee.
Sowas wie äh Script Monkey
oder wie das, ne wie heißt das?
Monkey Script
oder da gibt es auch so ein Browser
Automatisierungs Plugin.
Brauchst halt auch eine extra VM wo du das installierst.
Drin, dass du die Rechte hast aber ja.
Temper Monkey, ne wie heißt denn das neue?
Es heißt weder Crease Monkey, das ist das alte
Temper Monkey. Wie heißt denn das?
Es gibt doch ein neues.
Das haben wir doch hier, das haben wir doch hier
im Stream auch schon verwendet.
Ähm Violent
Monkey. Ja.
Das, das ist, das ist die
neueste Ausgabe davon.
Ja aber ernsthaft alles wo man irgendwie
Desktop Automatisierung machen muss
suckt doch. Also alles wo du
irgendwie rumklicken musst oder so.
Ausklick simulieren, das ist halt richtig, richtig
Müll. Was ist das hier?
Internets Anschluss.
Hm. Gibt es, gibt es
eigentlich noch Arche Internets oder
wieder wie die hießen?
Hm.
Da gab es doch mal so eine Fake Seite.
Vor zig Jahren.
Die auch so besonders christlich
gemacht haben. Kennt das
doch irgendjemand Arche Internets
oder wie das hieß oder wie hieß das denn?
So irgendwer, irgend so eine Fake Seite, die
so auf super christlich gemacht hat
und alle Anglizismen
verboten hat oder
oder nicht, nicht schreiben wollte. Sprich
die haben nicht Internet surfen gesagt,
die haben Internets Stehsegeln dann
immer geschrieben und sowas. War richtig cringe
Shit damals. Internets
Stehsegler. Ok.
Was ist das hier?
Kostenloses Internet von Giga
Fiber. Wo ist der Haken? Ok.
Giga Fiber. Giga
Fiber. Nicht Giga Chat.
Giga Fiber.
Ok. Das gucken wir uns tatsächlich mal
an. Da bin ich mal
Ich kenne den Youtube Channel
von MyDeals nicht.
Also keine Ahnung ob die Videos
was taugen, aber werden wir jetzt gleich sehen.
Kostenloses Internet
von Giga Fiber.
Golem. Ok. Ok.
Giga Fiber.
Gucken wir mal was
Golem dazu sagt. Chat geben.
Komm wir gucken uns einfach das Video an.
Internetanschluss der dauerhaft komplett kostenlos
ist. Das klingt erstmal viel zu gut um wahr
zu sein. Aber der Anbieter Giga Fiber
Klingt es auch. Und das
erste. Es klingt nicht nur
zu gut um wahr zu sein. Es klingt
zu gut, dass ich mir mittlerweile denken würde. Ok.
Wie
wollen die Geld machen und was machen
die mit meinem Traffic der da drüber
geht. Weil irgendwie muss sich das lohnen.
Und wahrscheinlich
unterm Strich lohnt es sich für mich
nicht. Obwohl es erstmal
kostenlos aussieht. Ich bin
ja mittlerweile sehr skeptisch was sowas angeht.
Generell, wenn dir einer was
schenken will, ist immer verdächtig.
Aber verspricht ganz genau das.
Wir haben uns das ganze mal ein bisschen genauer angeschaut.
Unter anderem auch einen Blick drauf geworfen. Wer denn
da überhaupt dahinter steckt. Und erklären euch
warum das ganze nicht ohne Haken ist.
Obwohl es in der Werbung eigentlich so versprochen wird.
Ja. Wer hätte das gedacht.
Ja am Dienstag haben wir erstmal alle nicht schlecht
gestaunt, als der Anbieter Giga
Fiber irgendwie komplett aus dem nichts aufgetaucht ist. Da haben sie alle
Keck Alu gemacht ne Runde. Und direkt mal mit nem Deal auf der
Plattform gelandet ist. Der Deal ist
ehrlicherweise kalt geworden. Und das hat auch einen gewissen
Grund. Denn das Versprechen klingt erstmal
eigentlich komplett unglaubwürdig.
Der Deal ist kalt geworden. Das ist auch
ein geiler Satz, Alter. Es wird damit geworben,
dass ein Internetanschluss dauerhaft
komplett kostenlos ist. Das heißt, es wird euch eine
Glasfaserleitung zu Hause komplett kostenlos
hingelegt. Ihr kriegt einen kostenlosen Router
gestellt. Und ihr zahlt auch für den monatlichen
Tarif 0 Euro. So und zum ersten
Punkt muss man direkt sagen, das ist definitiv
möglich, dass der Ausbau an sich gratis
erfolgt. Denn es gibt staatliche Förderungen und
Telekom etc. gehen auch hin und
bauen auch aus in Gebieten, wo entsprechend
viele Interessenten vorhanden sind.
Sie streichen dann die staatliche Förderung ein.
Und ihr kriegt am Ende dann als derjenige, der da
wohnt oder dem das Haus gehört, einen kostenlosen
Anschluss bis zumindest mal bei euch in den
Keller. Und könnt euch dann entscheiden, ob ihr
einen entsprechenden... Kommen dann irgendwelche
nicht
gut ausgebildeten
ja keine Ahnung
tschechischen Monteure
über Nacht, die dir das in den Keller hämmern oder so?
Das ist bestimmt super
shady allein schon an der Stelle.
...Tarif abschließen wollt oder nicht.
So aber beim zweiten Punkt, da wird's dann natürlich
irgendwie deutlich ja unglaubwürdiger erstmal.
Denn wie soll das funktionieren, dass der
Internetanschluss an sich dauerhaft kostenlos
ist? Da geht der Anbieter Gigafiber hin
und sagt auch selber schon relativ präsent
auf seiner Seite, es gibt eine Voraussetzung
dafür, dass dieser Tarif wirklich nichts
kostet. Denn damit wir das dauerhaft
kostenlos anbieten können, musst du lieber
Kunde ein sogenanntes Payment
Service Agreement mit einem unserer Partner
unterschreiben. Was? Und über den wickelst
du dann künftig deine wiederkehrenden
Zahlungen ab, wie zum Beispiel die
Monatsmiete oder Stromvertrag oder
sonstige Dinge, die regelmäßig... Ah! Ah ja, ja, ja,
okay, okay. Und die wollen dann
Transaktionsgebühren oder irgendwas
an irgendeiner Stelle, hä?
...sich anfallen. Ja und das ist schon
der erste Punkt... Das sind dann wahrscheinlich super shady
Bezahlanbieter.
Payment.eu oder sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, ob's das gibt, aber im Zweifelsfall
im Zweifelsfall schon. Mail.eu
Paying oder so.
PayPal Mail.eu
oder... Ich sage,
also die Werbung, die passt da nicht so... Oder, oder,
oder, oder... Punkt.
Ähm... Ist CN
die Top-Level Domain von China?
Oder ist das für... Hm...
Ja, ich glaube schon CN, ne?
Payment.cn
Denn die wirbt mit
0 Euro 0 Stress und
0 Haken. 0 Euro stimmt dann wohl, aber
0 Stress kann ich nicht einschätzen.
0 Haken zumindest nicht, denn klar ist das
ein Haken, wenn man sagt, hey, es müssen künftig
irgendwie gewisse Zahlungen darüber abgewickelt werden.
Ja. Thematisch an der Sache ist, selbst wenn
man ein bisschen sich in die AGB eingräbt auf der
Webseite, es steht nirgends klar drin,
zum einen, wer ist überhaupt dieser
Zahlungsdienstleister, mit dem ich da einen
separaten Vertrag abschließen muss, das steht
nämlich durchaus in den AGB drin, also dass
ein separater Vertrag aufgesetzt werden muss
mit diesem Zahlungsanbieter... Einen von uns
benannten Zahlungsanbieter in
Anspruch zu nehmen. Okay,
das heißt im Endeffekt, das ist Lückentext,
die können da irgendwas einsetzen,
was sie wollen.
Und wenn sie jetzt meinen, du musst
Krypto-Scam-Anbieter
aus Bangladesch nehmen, oder
wo auch immer, dann musst du das machen.
Ja, aber es werden halt wirklich auch nur Beispiele
genannt, was theoretisch an Zahlungen darüber
laufen könnte. Es wird gesagt, dass das Ganze
für dich als Kunde kostenlos sein soll,
es wird aber irgendwo nirgends erklärt, die Frage,
die ich mir stelle, warum sollte denn mein...
Wisst ihr, ich hab die Pfeifert-Idee
überhaupt richtig, richtig
ausgetribbelt jetzt.
Wenn Telekom und Vodafone und so bei dir
nicht Glasfaser ausbauen,
dann lässt du einfach von Gigafiber dir
ein Glasfaserkabel in den Keller legen
und dann kündigst du den Vertrag
und benutzt nie
den Zahlungsdienstleister.
Dann schmeißen die dich raus, aber du hast ein Glasfaser
im Keller und dann lässt du dich
vom ordentlichen Anbieter anschließen.
Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren, weil sie da
wahrscheinlich schon dran gedacht haben.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise,
wenn die sich das schon überlegt haben.
... sich überhaupt darauf
einlassen, dass die Miete künftig nicht mehr
von meinem Konto überwiesen wird, sondern von
einem externen Anbieter, der sich dazwischen klemmt
und der ja auch in irgendeiner Form mitverdienen möchte.
Also das erschließt sich mir zumindest auf
Basis der Datenlage, die wir aktuell haben
und wir nehmen hier am Mittwoch, den 25.10.
auf, nicht wirklich wie dieser
Payment-Service-Provider im Hintergrund da
tatsächlich gedenkt, Geld zu verdienen, weil irgendwie
muss es sich wieder finanzieren.
Muss ja als Kunde nicht unbedingt mein Problem
sein und wie kann ich mich denn überhaupt
dafür antragen? Und das ist der zweite Punkt,
wo es so ein bisschen seltsam wird, denn
offiziell wird damit geworben, dass man sich
erstmal die App runterladen soll, also es
gibt tatsächlich im App-Store eine
App von Gigafiber.
Das ist halt schon so ein Ding, ich würde mir noch nicht
mal diese App aufs Handy lassen.
... nichts anderes als
vor allem hier unten, ne?
Das soll Vertrauen irgendwie
vermitteln aus der TV-Werbung ZDF.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus,
dass sie nicht sich das eingeholt
haben vom ZDF, das Logo verwenden zu dürfen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob man das muss,
wenn man daraus schreibt, aus der TV-Werbung.
Ja, das ist ja nicht gelogen,
aber allein schon, weil da ZDF-Logo drunter
ist, schafft das für Oma und Opa
Vertrauen.
... Gigafiber und die macht momentan nichts
anderes, als dass ich damit einfach einen Antrag
abschicken kann. Also ich bekunde quasi über
die App Interesse daran, dass bitte bei mir
Glasfaser ausgebaut werden soll. Klar gibt's
Werbung auf ZDF. Und wenn sich das dann irgendwann ergibt, dann kriege ich
über die App eine Push-Benachrichtigung und werde dann
informiert, dass das bei mir möglich ist und
kann dann das Angebot annehmen. Ist insofern
auch nicht zu beanstanden, ist aber zumindest
ungewöhnlich. Klar gibt es Werbung im öffentlich-rechtlichen
Fernsehen. Ich glaube erst ab 20 Uhr nicht
mehr. ... über eine App zu machen,
weil, wenn es einfach nur ein Antrag ist, wozu
brauche ich da eine App? Und tatsächlich, wenn ich über den
Desktop die Seite aufrufe... Doch, die machen Werbung.
Ganz normal Werbung.
... und auf, ja, quasi die App klicke,
lande ich auch gar nicht bei der App, sondern bei einem stinknormalen
Formular, wo ich das irgendwie auch mitmachen kann. Also
was diese App so genau soll, erschließt
sich noch nicht ganz, beziehungsweise... Ja, Moment!
Doch, die sind erst mal
auf deinem Handy drauf. Das ist wahrscheinlich
das Interessante für die. ... schon, weil
wahrscheinlich werden darüber dann später mal
die Zahlungen abgewickelt. Kommen wir aber gleich noch zu.
Dann kommen wir mal zu dem Web-Auftritt dieses neuen Anbieters
und... Wisst ihr, was auch... ... diese Internetseite...
Wisst ihr, was auch sein kann? Alles nur Vermutung,
dass du... dass sie
wollen, dass die Leute das da drüber abschließen,
die die Leute dann scammen mit
irgendwelchen Zahlungsanbietern-Tricks
und nie im Keller überhaupt
jemals ein Glasfaseranschluss gelegt wird.
Man weiß ja nie, was da so
abgeht, ja? ...
... des Anbieters sieht erst mal sehr, sehr
gut gemacht aus und die sind auch zeitgleich mit
ihrem Web-Auftritt auf YouTube live gegangen mit einem
ganz eigenen Kanal, wo mehrere Erklärvideos
stehen, die halt so gewisse Themen behandeln. Die sind
auch alle wirklich gut produziert. Das offizielle
Werbevideo, was anscheinend
sogar auf dem ZDF lief, zumindest
einmal, dass die unten irgendwie damit werben können,
das sieht wirklich hochprofessionell aus, also da ist
tatsächlich Geld reingeflossen. Also macht erst mal
einen ganz guten Eindruck, aber wenn man mal ein bisschen
näher hinhört, was denn überhaupt in diesen Videos
kommuniziert wird, dann kann man zumindest
an gewissen Punkten skeptisch werden, vor allem
wenn man das dann abgleicht mit dem, was letztlich in den AGB
steht. Ich hab euch da mal so ein paar Punkte zusammengefasst.
Unter anderem wird da gesagt, in einem Video
es würde sich um ein komplett neues Netz
entlang der Infrastruktur der Deutschen Bahn
handeln. Komplett neues Netz, behaltet das gerne
im Hinterkopf. Dann wird noch gesagt... Da müsste die
Bahn ja mal was von wissen, oder? Ein
unabhängiges Netz, was geschützt vor
Ausfällen und Hackerangriffen ist. Ja, ich
verstehe Werbung, übertreibt auch gerne mal, aber
das ist halt faktisch einfach nicht möglich. Also
jeder, der sich so ein bisschen auskennt mit IT-Infrastruktur,
der weiß, es gibt kein ausfallsicheres
Netz gegen Hackerangriffe geschützt.
Naja, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
für die reine Infrastruktur
...
Also...
Was hat's damit
zu tun? Ehrlicherweise keine
Ahnung, wie sie dieses Versprechen einlösen wollen.
Kommt gleich noch ein Punkt, wo es vielleicht drauf anspielt,
aber auch das, in dem Moment, wo du irgendwie
ans normale Internet angeboten bist und
wir nicht von irgendeinem entfernten, internen Netzwerk reden oder so,
natürlich bist du auch grundsätzlich
vor Hackerangriffen nicht komplett geschützt. Okay, aber
mal selbst angenommen, dass jetzt wirklich dieses
flächendeckende Netz da gebaut wird,
ist das denn überhaupt realistisch, beziehungsweise
steht das denn überhaupt so in den AGB drin, dass die
wirklich ein komplett neues Netz bauen, was
dann auch wirklich von der Schiene entlang
bis in dein Haus geht? So wird es versprochen in der Werbung.
Und nee, denn in den AGB
steht was drin, was dem in meinen Augen komplett widerspricht.
Ich zitiere mal,
die Gigafiber baut in erster Linie in Partnerschaft
mit anderen Netzbetreibern aus,
verfügt aber selbst auch über eigene Baukapazitäten.
Also, so wie ich das verstehe,
würden die wahrscheinlich entlang der Schiene
ihr eigenes Netz legen und dann die
sogenannte letzte Meile, also quasi von der Schiene
dann irgendwie in die einzelnen Häuser,
natürlich halt auf die bereits vorhandene Infrastruktur,
beziehungsweise hoffen halt, dass die Telekom
irgendwo die Glasfaserstrenge hinzieht oder so,
ist ja auch eigentlich die sinnvollere Option, denn
wozu zweimal den Boden aufbodeln, wenn auch ein Anbieter
da schon liegt? Aber es widerspricht halt dem,
was in der Werbung suggeriert wird. Und in dem Moment,
wo ich natürlich die Leitung von jemand anderem mitbenutze,
habe ich schon kein autarkes Netz mehr
und auch der ganze Kram mit Ausfallsicherheit etc.,
das fällt dann alles raus. Also die Werbung verspricht
da schon mal mehr, als man sich selbst in die AGB schreibt
und da hört es noch nicht auf an der Stelle,
denn es geht noch weiter. Die Frage ist,
sind die denn überhaupt ein eigener Internetanbieter?
Und da gibt es einen weiteren Punkt, ebenfalls in den AGB,
das steht nämlich unter Punkt 2.3a.
Die Leistung wird durch ein
Telekommunikationsunternehmen erbracht.
Nach meinem Verständnis wäre das dann
zum Beispiel die Telekom, O2,
Vodafone oder irgendein anderer Anbieter,
der da bereits seine Kabel hingebodelt hat.
Und ganz konkret steht da drin, dass
Gigafiber einen Vertrag mit diesem
Unternehmen abschließt für diese Internetleitung
und quasi dafür die monatlichen
Kosten übernimmt. Für mich klingt das so, als würden
die gar...
Es hat ein bisschen was von Reseller, oder?
...keine eigene Leitung anbieten,
sondern einfach den Vertrag eines anderen
Anbieters übernehmen und dafür halt
die monatlichen Kosten übernehmen. Auch nicht
das, was in der Werbung eigentlich suggeriert wird,
nämlich, dass man ein komplett eigenes Netz aufbaut.
Jetzt könnt ihr auch sagen...
Bis jetzt würde ich sagen, ist das noch gar nicht mal
so schlimm, solange du dann wirklich
auch deinen Glasfaseranschluss kriegst.
Und wo ich mir viel mehr Gedanken
drüber machen würde zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt
ist, ob damit...
Was da mit den Zahlungsanbietern läuft,
weil das erscheint mir etwas shady alles.
...ja auch wieder nicht, wenn ich am Ende tatsächlich
einen kostenlosen Anschluss habe. Fair enough.
Gucken wir nochmal, wie die das denn denken
überhaupt zu monetarisieren. Und zwar wird
unter anderem gesagt...
Du bezahlst bequem über deinen sicheren Router.
Keine Ahnung, wie genau das vonstatten geht.
Du bezahlst bequem über deinen sicheren Router?
Hä?
Ich dachte, ich muss nichts bezahlen.
Oder ich bezahle dann meine Miete über
den sicheren Router? Oder was?
Ups.
Was war das?
Du bezahlst bequem über deinen sicheren Router.
Keine Ahnung, wie genau das vonstatten geht.
Das hat dann so einen Schlitz wie einen Geldautomat, der Router.
...gehen soll, aber das erst mal
festgehalten. In einem anderen Video wird gesagt...
Tatsächlich funktioniert der Gigafiber-Router
während seiner Nutzung wie ein VPN.
Aber so meine erste Überlegung, ja okay,
vielleicht leiten die sämtlichen Internetverkehr
all ihrer Kunden über deren eigene Server
Der Router funktioniert wie ein VPN?
Daten erfassen, wer was wann wo
aufruft, gegebenenfalls was wo kauft.
Leute, ich muss mir die Werbung von denen jetzt mal kurz
im Original angucken.
Wie heißen die?
GIGA
FIBER
Meint ihr das ist die Werbung?
Ja, oder?
Wir machen Deutschland mit der neu verlegten
Glasfaser-Infrastruktur schnell,
sicher, effizient
und zukunftsfähig.
Hier wird die Vision
zur Realität.
Dafür erschaffen wir...
So diese 0815 Innovationsmusik
im Hintergrund.
...ein komplett neues Netz.
Verlegen es entlang der Gleise
der Deutschen Bahn, bis in die Häuser
und Unternehmen.
Ein schnelles Netz.
Ein sicheres Netz.
Ein unabhängiges Netz.
Geschützt vor
Ausfällen und Hackangriffen.
Zusätzlich bauen wir
unnötige Bürokratie ab.
Die Bilder haben damit gar nichts
zu tun, wahrscheinlich sind das irgendwelche
Stock-Footage oder so, das ich gekauft habe.
...in ganz Deutschland.
Die Bilder haben damit zu tun, dass es
entlang der Deutschen Bahn geht halt.
Keine komplexen Systeme.
Die Sicherheit deiner Daten.
Ruhe und schnelle
Up- und Downloadraten.
Effizienz.
Genau dafür steht das Giga-Fibernetz.
Das Internet
wird dich nichts kosten.
Da wir Bezahlsysteme revolutionieren
und damit vereinfachen.
Okay, und deswegen ist es komisch,
kostenlos für mich.
Klingt ja super.
Komplett schlüssige Begründung, oder?
Ist doch logisch.
Dass vereinfachte
Bezahlsysteme für mich kostenloses
Internet bedeuten, oder?
Also, obviously.
Der Zusammenhang ist doch komplett klar.
Es wird wie die Luft
zum Atmen.
Selbstverständlich und kostenlos.
Wie die Luft zum Atmen.
Wir schenken dir das Internet.
Zum Tarif von 0 Euro.
Wir sind die Pioniere,
die dir den Weg in eine neue,
sichere, schnelle und lebenswerte Zukunft bereiten.
Die haben
tolle Stockvideos genommen
und Leute schauen in die Luft.
Wir haben gerade erst angefangen.
Giga-Fiber.
Das 0-Euro-Internet für alle.
Moment, aber das mit dem VPN und so
steht da nicht.
Für wen gilt das 0-Euro-Angebot?
Das ist ein Trollvideo von
Marvin.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Das 0-Euro-Internet für alle
ist genau das. 0-Euro-Internet
für alle. Für Privatpersonen
und Unternehmen in Deutschland.
Risiko für dich? Keins.
Das ist alles sehr sass.
Denn mit dem Ausfüllen des Antrags
hast du noch keinen Vertrag unterschrieben.
Und dein bisheriger Anschluss läuft
vorerst ganz normal weiter.
Also sichere dir jetzt deine Chance
auf das 0-Euro-Internet.
So sass, ich weiß nicht.
So, wo ist das denn mit diesem VPN-Router?
Alter, warum sitzt da einer halbnackig rum?
Tobias hat beschissenes Internet.
Ich will das mit dem VPN.
Wo könnte das
dabei sein?
Wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal,
wer im Impressum steht.
Falls es da sowas gibt.
Wenn es eine deutsche Seite da, ne?
Aber muss es?
Shit, das ist bei mir um die Ecke.
Das ist...
Ich habe damit nichts zu tun, Leute.
Ja, das ist...
Das ist...
Das ist direkt an der Brücke.
Direkt an der Unter-Main...
Was heißt hier? Unter-Main-Brücke?
Da, wo man, wenn man ein bisschen weiter geht,
dann man an dieser Plakette vorbeikommt.
Auch hier wurde der erste
Büro ausgegeben und sowas.
Wir gucken.
Leute, Leute, wir gucken mal kurz.
Das ist unten am Main.
Deswegen gibt es dort wahrscheinlich
kein Street View.
Ach ne, ah, okay, das ist nicht unten am Main.
Das ist schon die Straße oben, okay.
Wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal Street View, ob wir da irgendwas sehen.
Bürofläche zu vermieten.
Letztes Jahr im November.
Okay.
Und vorher war da Nettigate.
Interessant.
Erkennt ihr
da sonst noch was drauf?
Nettigate kenn ich nicht.
Aber die sind ja auch
hier drinne. Da ist...
Ja, genau, hier unten ist der Main.
Und hier
ist das Bild letztens entstanden
am Main.
Erkennt ihr es? Das ist das Bild, was ich euch
eben auf Twitter gezeigt hab.
So ungefähr von...
Ja, nicht ganz.
Von hier habe ich das Bild gemacht,
wo ich mit dem Fahrrad unten am Main war.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das sind andere, nicht die PFSense-Leute.
Aha, da sind die, okay.
TikTok!
Ja, wenn schon, dann gleich richtig.
Linktree auch am Start.
Pass auf, Onlyfans
kommt jetzt gleich.
Hm.
Ja, ein bisschen sass ist das schon alles,
gell?
Das wirkt auch so, als hätten die schon
drei, fünf Millionen Anschlüsse gelegt.
Haben sie halt auch nicht.
Etwas sass wirkt das alles, ja?
Was ist das? Ne.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ja, mal weiter gucken.
Und verdienen dann irgendwie an den Daten.
Aber das wiederum fällt auch zusammen durch nen anderen Punkt,
denn es wird wiederum gesagt, du musst den Router gar nicht nutzen.
Also, wir haben ja auch in Deutschland sowas wie
Routerfreiheit. Es wird explizit in den
AGB geschrieben, du kannst auch einfach deinen eigenen
Router nutzen. Dann funktioniert die ganze Konstellation
ja schon mal nicht mehr. Es sei denn wiederum,
der Router ist die Voraussetzung für das...
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich musst du
über die App, du musst
daheim an einem Anschluss mit der App...
Ob da jemals überhaupt
Anschlüsse geschaltet werden, ist ja noch fraglich.
Null-Euro-Angebot, das steht da
aber so auch nicht drin, sondern da steht nur, du brauchst halt
diesen Payment-Service-Vertrag mit dem
anderen Anbieter, haben wir gesagt, ist nicht
näher definiert. Alles wirklich sehr
undurchschaubar, wie die überhaupt Geld verdienen möchten.
Jetzt könnte man argumentieren, wenn ich mich da eintrage,
schließe ich ja noch keinen Vertrag ab und in dem Moment,
wo das möglich ist, kommen da vielleicht weitere Details
und ich kann's immer noch dann entscheiden.
Ja, aber ich würde zumindest mal gucken,
ist das denn überhaupt realistisch, dass das, was die
gerade da irgendwie kommunizieren, dass
das in irgendeiner Form auch so umgesetzt wird.
Und da warne ich euch jetzt ein bisschen vor, jetzt gehen wir so ein bisschen
ins Rabbit Hole und da kann man sehr, sehr tief abtauchen.
Wir kommen uns nämlich an, wer steckt
überhaupt hinter Gigafiber. Erste Anlaufstelle
ist natürlich die offizielle Webseite,
wir rufen einfach mal das Impressum auf und da steht
diesen Namen Gigafiber GmbH.
Das hab ich auch gerade gefunden.
Genau in dieser Form, denn es kommen gleich noch ein paar weitere Player
ins Spiel, die alle so ein bisschen ähnlich heißen.
Da steht auch ein gewisser Herr Jörg Müller als Geschäftsführer
im Impressum, merken wir uns ebenfalls.
Positiv erstmal, diese Gigafiber GmbH
ist Mitglied in zwei sogenannten Branchenverbänden,
wo es um den Breitbandausbau geht.
Also da findet man zumindest auf diesen
beiden renommierten Websites auch einen Eintrag dazu.
Insofern scheint da schon grundsätzlich so eine Art
Vorcheck stattgefunden zu haben. Ich gehe jetzt einfach mal
davon aus, dass man sich da nicht irgendwie draufkaufen kann,
sondern zumindest mal mit den Herrschaften gesprochen haben muss.
Erstmal ein ganz gutes Indiz und da schauen wir
jetzt mal genauer hin, wer denn hinter dieser Gigafiber
GmbH steckt und da schauen wir einfach mal ins gute
alte Handelsregister, das ist online zu finden
und da kann man Informationen zu jedem Unternehmen
in Deutschland abrufen und wenn ich da in die Suche gehe
und einfach mal die Gigafiber GmbH eingebe
und dann sage bitte genaue Ergebnisse,
dann kriege ich interessanterweise direkt
zwei Ergebnisse angezeigt, nämlich erstmal die
GmbH, die ich gesucht habe und es gibt auch noch
die Gigafiber Netz GmbH,
die ebenfalls einen Sitz in Frankfurt hat,
also offenbar in irgendeiner Form eine Schwester,
Tochter, Klonfirma, whatever ist.
Wir schauen uns natürlich erstmal die erste an und da fällt direkt auf,
die ist ursprünglich als sogenannte Vorrats GmbH
gegründet worden. Sieht erstmal shady aus,
weil das auch so einen generischen Namen hat, ist aber nicht
unbedingt ungewöhnlich, eine sogenannte Vorrats GmbH
wird von darauf spezialisierten Firmen
quasi als Blanko GmbH gegründet,
die machen das mehrfach, also legen mehrere dieser
GmbHs an, dass sie dann, wenn irgendein Kunde
zu ihnen kommt und sagt, ey, ich brauche mal spontan eine GmbH,
die quasi schon parat haben,
dann wird die einfach nur noch schnell umgeschrieben, also
kriegt man einen anderen Namen, kriegt einen anderen Geschäftsführer,
das geht aber deutlich schneller, als wenn man quasi
from scratch eine neue GmbH gründet,
hat vor allem auch noch den Vorteil, dass die dann
auf dem Papier schon länger existiert und
Banken gucken da ganz gerne mal hin und wie die dann ursprünglich
mal hieß, interessiert die nicht. Das an sich kein Indikator
dafür, dass das irgendwie unseriös ist.
Und deutlich spannender wird es, wenn man sich anschaut,
wer sind denn die Gesellschafter? Und das kann man sich ebenfalls
im Handelsregister abrufen und das ist die
sogenannte Giga-Fiber-Optik-Products-LLC
mit Sitz in
Dubai.
Giga-Fiber-Optik-Products-LLC
Da weißt du ja schon wieder Bescheid, ey.
Passt ja auch wieder,
dass das Ganze in Frankfurt ist.
Frankfurt, Goethestraße,
Louis Vuitton-Store, Zaldi-Kollektion,
Fick auf Sponsor.
LLC mit Sitz in Dubai.
Vielleicht hat da ApoRed was mit
zu tun, ja, wer weiß.
Ich als jemand, der sich in der Branche nicht unbedingt auskennt, bin da
zumindest erstmal so ein bisschen stutzig und denke mir, hä, warum ist denn da
jemand aus Dubai, der da investieren möchte und
der in Deutschland angeblich komplett
flächendeckend Glasfaser legen möchte. Gucken wir aber mal
bisschen genauer hin, was es mit dieser LLC auf sich
hat, denn auch in Dubai gibt es ein Handelsregister,
wo ich wiederum die Daten eintragen kann
und da kriege ich zwei interessante Dinge
ausgespuckt. Zum einen, es handelt sich um eine
Ein-Personen-Firma, also das ist
kein großes Unternehmen und
die Kontakt-E-Mail, die da angegeben ist,
ist eine völlig andere
und da lande ich auf der Website AuroraPi,
was irgendwie so eine Art Consulting-Firma
ist und ist nicht so ganz genau
ersichtlich, was die macht, aber es steht zumindest
Das ist schon alles bisschen sass,
ne? Irgendwie, dass die jetzt großartig mit
Breitbandausbau betraut wäre und das ist schon der
erste Punkt, wo ich sage, okay, das sind schon ein paar
seltsame Verknüpfungen, aber da hört es noch nicht
auf, denn ich habe ja gerade gesagt, es gibt noch eine zweite
GmbH, die fast genau gleich heißt, die
Gigafiber-Netz GmbH, ist ebenfalls auf einem
Herrn Jörg Müller registriert, der im Impressum
steht bei der anderen Firma und ist ebenfalls
mit dem Gesellschafter aus Dubai
verbandelt. Der einzige Unterschied ist, das war
keine Vorrats-GmbH, das heißt, die ist wirklich
quasi neu gegründet worden. Was genau
der Hintergrund ist, dass man diese zwei Firmen hat,
weiß ich nicht genau, vielleicht soll die eine den Ausbau
übernehmen, die andere ist nur für die Verwaltung zuständig,
aber zumindest haben die auch genau die gleiche
Satzung, also wirklich wortgleich,
deswegen für mich auch so ein Punkt, den ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen
kann. Jetzt wird es aber noch eine ganze Spur wilder,
denn ich habe noch eine dritte GmbH gefunden
über Umwege, das ist die sogenannte Giga
Connect GmbH, der Name, also erneut relativ
ähnlich, da ist alleine schon dieser Werdegang dieser GmbH
noch deutlich seltsamer, denn ursprünglich
war das 2021 mal eine Vermögensverwaltung
für eine 81-jährige
Dame. Ja genau, ihr habt richtig gehört.
Was?
Nach dieser
Vermögensgesellschaft ist es dann umgewandelt
worden in eine Hilfsorganisation
für die Ukraine und nachdem es dann
diese Hilfsorganisation für die Ukraine war,
ist es umbenannt worden in die Giga Connect GmbH.
Es gab natürlich jeweils auch einen Geschäftsführer,
einen Geschäftsführerwechsel und am Ende
dieser Kette, also nach dem aktuellen Stand,
ist der Geschäftsführer ein gewisser Herr
Lars-Peter Diebold, also nicht unser Herr
Jörg Müller. Jetzt könnte man erneut sagen,
okay, das ist ein Zufall, die heißen halt
einfach beide so. Sehr seriös. Aber wenn man sich mal
näher anschaut, was es mit Lars-Peter Diebold
auf sich hat, dann findet man relativ schnell
seinen LinkedIn-Eintrag und da findet man auch
genau das Werbematerial von Giga Fiber. Okay,
okay, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Hier, direkt aus Chat-GPT-Lebenslauf,
Visionary
Inventor
Das ist hier, schreibe mir ein
Business-Stonks-Profil
für LinkedIn, Chat-GPT.
I love
to build new things that scale fast.
Oh Mann,
das ist ja 0815-Geschwätze,
also
mehr leeres Business-Stonks-Gelaber
kannst du ja kaum noch machen als den Text
hier. Sustainable
Win-Win-Situations
I do not like to slow down.
Not many words,
just actions.
CRM, Big Data, Search Engine,
Programming and Implementation, WiFi and
Connect. Das ergibt so überhaupt
keinen Sinn zusammen alles.
I'm a defender
for free, free Internet and
Media. Das ist doch Chat-GPT generiert
das Ding, Alter, oder?
Der Text ergibt überhaupt keinen
Sinn. Giga Fiber,
er präsentiert sich da selbst auch als offiziell
Gründer von Giga Fiber.
Richtiger Macher.
Ganz interessant, dass er dann aber nicht im Impressum steht
bei Giga Fiber. Und da findet man auch noch so ein paar
andere Infos, unter anderem was sie vorhaben,
nämlich beispielsweise, dass sie ab dem Januar
2024 mit dem Ausbau beginnen wollen,
bis einschließlich Dezember 2026
und insgesamt 33.000
Kilometer Glasfaser legen wollen.
Das dürfte dann wahrscheinlich dem Schienennetz der Deutschen Bahn
entsprechen. Also grundsätzlich ist dieser Wille
also vorhanden. Wenn wir bei der Giga Connect GmbH
dann reinschauen, wer da denn der
Gründer ist, dann ist das ebenfalls eine andere Gesellschaft,
die wiederum in Dubai ansässig ist, mit dem Namen
Hi Wi-Fi Connect IT-Service.
Ach du Scheiße, da blickt ja keiner
mehr durch. Da kann man auch ein bisschen schauen, wenn man sich
auf Herr Diebolds Profil umschaut, dann findet man
relativ schnell die sogenannte International Wi-Fi
Connect GmbH, bei der er auch wiederum
als Geschäftsführer angetragen ist. Das hört nicht mehr auf.
Also das ist letztlich seine GmbH.
Das Ganze auch in Dubai ansässig, also
ebenso wie wohl Herr Diebold, zumindest
zwischenzeitlich mal. Entsprechend kann man sagen, dass der
eigentliche Charakter hinter dieser Firma Herr Lars-Peter
Diebold ist. Also das scheint auf seine Idee
ausgewachsen zu sein, das Ganze.
Naja, Gelnhausen, du, der hat ja bis jetzt anscheinend
noch nichts verbrochen damit.
Es ist ja nicht verboten, verschiedene Unternehmen
zu gründen. Bis jetzt ist das ja
ja noch alles in Ordnung.
Und es muss ja auch gar nicht sein,
dass da irgendwie...
Letztendlich muss man ja immer noch sagen,
alles nur Vermutungen.
Auch wenn es sehr
suspekt ist alles.
Wenn man nach dieser Hi Wi-Fi Connect GmbH
googelt, dann landet man auch auf einer Internetseite,
wo tatsächlich ein entsprechendes Produkt
angeboten wird mit dem Namen Hi Wi-Fi,
wo es sich um, kurz zusammengefasst, eine
API zu handeln scheint, die in Apps integriert
werden kann und die unter anderem dazu
dient, Kunden, die da in den Laden betreten,
in dem Moment anzusprechen und denen quasi eine Push-Nachricht
aufs Handy zu schicken und zu sagen, hey, herzlich willkommen.
Vielleicht sowas wie, hier hast du einen Gutschein.
Also es ist ein fertiges, marktreifes Produkt, was sich
zwar nicht an Endverbraucher richtet, aber laut
eigener Firmenreferenz unter anderem in die
DB Navigator App und auch in die
Samsung Health App integriert ist, was ja schon relativ
große Namen sind. Zwei zu gut hat es jetzt erstmal
nichts mit Glasfaser zu tun, aber zumindest mit
Internet im weitesten Sinne, also die restlichen
Referenzen von Herrn Diebold zeigen. Also er scheint wohl
dicke zu sein mit der Bahn. Er mit
diesem Bereich durchaus Erfahrungen gemacht hat bei
verschiedenen Firmen. Er war unter anderem auch irgendwie
in den WLAN-Ausbau in den Zügen der Deutschen Bahn
involviert, also da scheint eine gewisse
Vorkenntnis auf jeden Fall vorhanden zu sein.
Und da sieht man unter anderem auch, er hatte auch mal
eine Station beim TÜV und das ist insofern
interessant, weil das wieder die Brücke schlägt
zum Herrn Jörg Müller, denn wenn wir uns mal sein
LinkedIn-Profil anschauen, denn der gute Herr hat einen Großteil
seiner beruflichen Laufbahn beim TÜV verbracht.
Das ist ein gut gemachtes Video.
Ich finde, die haben da sehr viel
nachgebohrt, was da wie wo
abgeht. Unter anderem im
Bereich Breitbandausbau.
Die versprechen, was sie nicht einhalten, weißt du doch
gar nicht. Bis jetzt
ist noch nichts passiert. Es sieht
äußerst verdächtig aus. Ich glaube nicht, dass da was
passieren wird, ob bis jetzt noch nichts passiert.
Also es sind auf jeden Fall Leute involviert, die sich
grundsätzlich auskennen mit dem Bereich.
Mir erschließt sich aber zum einen nicht,
warum wird da dieses Firmenkonstrukt aufgezogen
mit irgendwie verschiedenen Verbindungen
und dann geht das einmal nach Dubai und dann geht's zu einer
anderen Subfirma und dann immer hin und her und
eigentlich ist die Firma, die dahinter steckt, aber viel kleiner.
Außerdem erklärt sich immer noch nicht, welcher
Zahlungsanbieter steckt denn da überhaupt hinter. Ist das
ein komplett Neugegründeter, denn das geht ja
auch nicht. Man weiß es ja nicht.
Das ist ja auch das Ding. Werbung
und AGB widersprechen sich jetzt schon. Wenn das
schon illegal ist, müsstest du wahrscheinlich 90%
der Firmen, die Werbung
machen, zumachen. Also ich glaube,
das
dürfte nicht das Kriterium sein.
Letztendlich bist du ja
frei, deine Verträge so zu gestalten.
Wie du willst. Wenn das jemand unterschreibt,
unter Meinung ist, er will das machen,
ist das okay. Bis jetzt ist ja noch nichts
Großartiges passiert.
Also das mit dem Zahlungsanbieter
finde ich allerdings sehr, sehr fragwürdig.
Das ist das
allererste,
warum ich, neben den ganzen
anderen Punkten, das nie im Leben in Erwägung
ziehen würde. Die können ja da
wirklich Wildcard einsetzen, was sie wollen.
Und vielleicht habe ich da den
ausschlaggebenden Punkt gefunden, wer dahinter
stecken könnte. Ich nenne es extra im
Konjunktiv, denn in Verbindung mit HiWiFi
findet man wiederum eine übergeordnete Website
mit dem Namen GigaConnect Group.
Und auf dieser Website... Alter, wie
viele GigaConnect
Unternehmen gibt es denn da jetzt?
Das ist schon das fünfte oder so. Auf der Webseite geht es ehrlicherweise deutlich
schwammiger zu, weil es da nicht um ein konkretes Produkt
geht. Aber ich zitiere mal einen Bereich.
Es beginnt mit tiefgreifenden methodischen Kenntnissen,
fundierter Transformationserfahrung und einem
hohen Maß an technologischem Verständnis
sowie tiefer Expertise in der
Wertgenerierung aus Startup.
Aber das ist auch schon ein ziemlicher Bullshit-Satz,
oder? Also
möglichst viele Worte
und tolle Begriffe.
Fundierter
Transformationserfahrung. Ja, da
stehen wahrscheinlich die CEOs
und sonst was dieser Welt auf solche Wörter.
Ich finde, da ist immer sehr
viel heiße Luft. Ja, aber der
Wertgenerierung aus Daten klingt
natürlich schon ein bisschen
fragwürdiger.
Das neue Gold des 21.
Jahrhunderts gewinnen.
Gewinnen wir durch modernste künstliche Intelligenz
eigene APIs? Äh,
okay. Das ist
auch so. Einfach mal einen
Technikbegriff reingeschrieben,
ob es jetzt irgendwie Sinn macht oder nicht
an der Stelle. Dies alles
end-to-end aus einer
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Anführungszeichen gesetzt auch auf der Webseite.
Das neue Gold des 21. Jahrhunderts
gewinnen wir durch modernste künstliche
Intelligenz, eigene APIs und
Computer-Technologien. Das alles end-to-end
aus einer Hand über den ganzen Transformationsprozess.
Und da geht es dann offenbar wirklich um Daten
von Kunden, denn das neue Gold des 21.
Jahrhunderts spielt ganz klar darauf an, dass
unter anderem Facebook, Google und die ganzen anderen
großen Unternehmen sich eine goldene Nase
damit verdienen, dass sie halt wirklich sehr, sehr viel
über ihre Kunden wissen und das an die Werbewirtschaft
verkaufen können. Und wenn ich da so eins und eins zusammenzähle,
wäre das zumindest meine Vermutung, dass das
auch irgendwo eine Rolle spielen wird, denn wenn ich
die ganzen Sachen über die App abwickeln muss oder
gegebenenfalls über diesen Router, dann werden
natürlich auch relativ viele Daten erhoben, die dann in
irgendeiner Form monetarisiert werden können. Und um den
Zahlungsdienstleister anzusprechen, auf den ich hinaus wollte,
auf dieser Website findet sich ebenfalls ein Logo von
VR Payments. Und VR sind tatsächlich
die guten alten Volksbanken, Reifeisenbanken.
Ah, die sind auch am Start. Eine Website von denen, also
das ist ein Zahlungsdienstleister, mit dem zumindest
diese Firma zusammenarbeitet oder
zusammengearbeitet hat. Unter anderem sind die
wohl auch irgendwie in Giropay involviert
und meine These wäre jetzt zumindest,
dass dieser Zahlungsdienstleister, der da
im Hintergrund steckt, VR Payments
sein könnte. Er erneut das Ganze im Konjunktiv.
Es muss nicht zwingend sein, es kann auch jemand komplett
anderes sein, aber wenn man diesen ganzen Strängen
so folgt, ist das die für mich logische
Schlussfolgerung. Und ihr merkt schon, das geht
wirklich sehr, sehr ins Detail und ich habe hier wirklich noch
sehr, sehr viel ausgelassen. Also man kann da sehr, sehr
viel Zeit verbringen, diesen ganzen Strängen zu folgen.
Ihr könnt das gerne auch zu Hause nachmachen und
das nicht verwagen müssen. Andi Glitsch denke ich auch.
Es gibt genug, die das machen.
Und schaut da gerne, ob ihr vielleicht noch andere Verbindungen
findet, die möglicherweise noch irgendwie
aussagekräftiger sind. Mein persönliches Fazit
an dieser Stelle, es gibt dann doch ein paar
Haken, denn es ist unter anderem ungeklärt,
Es ist sehr shady alles auf jeden Fall.
wie dieses Monetarisierungsmodell letztlich
konkret aussieht. Dann finde ich zumindest
dieses Konstrukt aus verschiedenen GmbHs
mit verschiedenen Inhabern und irgendwie
Subfirmen über Dubai zumindest mal
etwas merkwürdig. Und da habe ich auch unseren Chef
gefragt, der sich mit sowas eher auskennt. Der sagte auch,
ja, das ist, wenn man sowas seriös aufziehen
möchte, zumindest mal ungewöhnlich.
Und der letzte Punkt, gewisse Aussagen in den
AGB widersprechen auch schlichtweg den
Aussagen aus der Werbung, was für mich grundsätzlich
schon mal ein No-Go ist, denn ich möchte bitte auch
in der Werbung, selbst wenn man da ein bisschen blumiger
die Dinge formuliert, nicht irgendwie komplett andere
Dinge erzählt kriegen, als dann letztlich im
Kleingedruckten stehen. Ich bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob es
jemals ein
Internetanschlüsse,
also Glasfaser gelegt werden. Haltet lieber erstmal
die Füße still, selbst wenn ihr auf den ersten Blick da nichts
zu verlieren habt. Es ist nicht wirklich durchschaubar
und ich würde da erstmal Abstand von nehmen,
euch da einzutragen. Wenn sich da neue Infos ergeben,
dann kann man sich ja immer nochmal überlegen und
zuletzt... Wir können mal Peter
Wobblor eintragen oder sowas
und gucken, was dann passiert.
Eine kurzes Plädoyer halten an die
Journalisten da draußen, denn ich bin explizit keiner.
Warum an den Schienen der DB anscheinend?
Weil der Gründer Connections
zur Bahn hat. Beispielsweise Leute wie bei
Heiser Online oder auch bei Golem oder bei
Computerbase, sich da mal ein bisschen näher hinzusetzen.
Dann auch mal natürlich bei Gigafiber offiziell
nachzufragen und die mit gewissen Konstellationen
auch einfach zu konfrontieren. Vielleicht haben die ja eine Erklärung
dafür, die ich jetzt einfach nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Da war jetzt innerhalb dieser Kürze der Zeit nicht die
Möglichkeit zu, sonst hätte ich das natürlich auch gerne gemacht.
Aber ich wollte gerne vor dem Wochenende noch mit
einem Video dazu rausgehen, um euch da einfach drauf
hinzuweisen, dass es da nach aktuellem Stand
Unstimmigkeiten gibt und ich da erstmal persönlich
die Finger von lassen würde.
Ja, nachvollziehbar.
Das Werbevideo mit VPN ist...
Was passiert mit meinen Daten?
Okay.
Diese Innovationsmusik
im Hintergrund, Alter. Ich kann sie nicht mehr hören.
Das haben total viele.
Ja.
...GVO-Normen vertraulich verarbeitet.
Tatsächlich...
Ob Dubai sich
daran hält?
...funktioniert der Gigafiber-Router während seiner Nutzung
wie ein VPN. Du bist also
sogar gegen jeden geschützt, der unerlaubt
an deine Daten will.
Das ergibt überhaupt
gar keinen Sinn.
...ein besseres, sicheres, unabhängiges,
resilientes Netz
zum Preis von 0 Euro.
Du hast mehr Fragen zum Datenschutz?
Dann check die FAQs
in der App. Alles, was du
für dein Gratis-Internet tun musst, ist
App herunterladen, Daten
eintippen und absenden.
...wirklich
gar keinen Sinn.
Aber...
Was hat 100 Mbit mit Glasfaser
zu tun? Das ist schlechter
als viele DSL-Anschlüsse noch.
Wobei, ne,
ist bei VDSL nicht sogar bei 100 Mbit
Schluss? Ne,
250, gell?
Ich glaub, VDSL geht bis maximal 250.
Aber dann auch nur unter
optimalsten Bedingungen.
Also, ich würde mir das sofort anschließen
lassen, sobald's bei uns
Glasfaser gibt. Instant.
Was stimmt, was schreibt Golem?
Viele Fragezeichen beim
neuen Anbieter.
Oh, ne, das les ich
jetzt nicht drei Seiten.
Ein Gigafiber-Sprecher versicherte Golem
klar ist, dem Kunden werden in keinem Fall Kosten
für die Erstellung... Okay, bla bla bla.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Bin gespannt. Extrem langes,
aber gutes Video. Das hab ich sogar schon offen,
aber das will ich mir jetzt nicht angucken. 1 Stunde 24,
da wären wir heute nicht fertig.
Wenn ich ein 1 Stunde 24
Video gucke, da brauch ich
so wie ich mich kenne, drei Stunden für, man.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier? Was ist das denn?
Windows neuer Servicevertrag,
totale Überwachung, Verhaltenskodex, Faktencheck.
Oh je. Da werden die Fakten
gecheckt.
Die checken wir erstmal.
Später. 1 Stunde 24, das ist
zu lang.
Was ist das?
Mit und ohne Cloud, versteckte Funktionen
von Google und Apple Fotos.
Ja...
Juck mich jetzt nicht so.
Morphoids hat YouTubes neue
Adblock-Strategie. Und was das bedeutet?
Das bedeutet, dass YouTube gucken mehr abfuck wird.
Ohne...
Oh, ehrlich, so lauter.
Super demotivierte Software.
Ähm...
Das bedeutet, dass wenn man nicht YouTube Premium
hat, es noch mehr abfuck wird zu gucken.
Es reicht ja nicht nur doppelte
Anzeigen am Anfang mit Roll-Anzeigen
und alles mögliche, jetzt auch noch
unskippable Anzeigen.
Ja, aber das ist zu lang, das Videos gucke ich
jetzt nicht. Der macht immer gute Videos.
Ja. Aber das ist mir
echt zu lang.
Haben wir noch irgendwas Gutes?
Und sonst gucke ich mir jetzt an.
Keck Alu.
Wie Linux insgeheim die Welt
kontrolliert.
Das klingt schon bisschen reißerisch, oder?
Guck mal, ich krieg
meine eigenen Videos empfohlen, Pog.
Muss ich anklicken.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und heute will ich euch mal...
Muss ich anklicken. Viewtime.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das Beste ist, sich YouTube Premium
zu holen, dann hat man das Problem nicht.
Und wenn euch YouTube Premium
zu teuer ist, dann kauft euch YouTube
Premium in Indien.
Jetzt.
Was zum...
Warum gibt es ein neues Gothic 1
Remake, oder was?
Oder wie, oder wat?
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht komplett. Interessiert mich einfach nur.
Ende September gibt es den Rollenspiel-Klassiker Gothic 1
auch auf der Switch.
Ach, auf der Switch.
Ja, das sollte sogar die Switch schaffen.
Bis sie den Account
sperren. Wieso? Werden da wirklich Accounts
für gesperrt?
Also ich habe hier einen privaten Account.
Da habe ich das schon eine Weile.
Wobei es gar nicht mein
privater Account ist.
Mit aus Indien.
Okay, Max, genug Viewtime.
Microsofts neuer Servicevertrag
erlaubt totale Überwachung aller Benutzer.
Also wenn ich die letzten Jahre über
eins gelernt habe, ist
sobald irgendwie
die Möglichkeit besteht,
wird es auch zunehmend ausgenutzt
und gemacht.
Und das wird hier relativ
ähnlich sein.
Und zumindest besteht hier das Potential,
dass das relativ ähnlich wird.
Ich meine, auch wenn es
ein komplett anderes Beispiel ist,
und da hat es mit dem Microsoft-Vertrag nichts zu tun.
Eines der Beispiele, wo man das denke ich ganz gut sehen kann,
sobald die Möglichkeit da ist,
sobald die
Voraussetzungen da sind,
dass es dann auch benutzt wird für Sachen,
die explizit angekündigt wurden,
dass sie nicht gemacht werden ist.
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch daran, als
vor dem habe ich schon ein paar Videos geguckt.
Von dem Typ von
Jorgs
Jorgenson
Ja, von dem habe ich auch schon ein paar Videos geguckt.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also, ein Beispiel dafür ist,
erinnert euch vielleicht noch
daran, wo man während
Corona dazu angehalten war, wenn man in
ein Restaurant geht, aufzuschreiben
so Kontaktdaten,
dass man im Fall der Fälle, wenn da
was ist, dann kontaktiert werden kann.
War sinnvoll,
im Nachhinein fand ich das jetzt auch nicht so wild,
aber
was man daran gesehen hat ist,
ein paar Wochen
später, obwohl das nur
rein zweckgebunden verwendet werden sollte,
kam die bayerische
Polizei um die Ecke und hat gesagt,
ja, ja dann, dann
gebt uns doch mal die Daten, wir wollen da jetzt auch
Zugriff drauf haben. Und daran sieht man,
sobald die Möglichkeit besteht,
die Voraussetzung geschaffen ist,
dann wird das, dann dauert
es meistens auch nicht lang, bis das Maximale
gemacht wird. Das heißt, ich bin bei sowas
immer skeptisch, wenn sich irgendwelche
Unternehmen, oder es ist egal wer, wenn sich irgendeiner
hinstellt und sagt,
wir schaffen uns mal super weitreichende Rechte,
aber macht euch keine
Sorgen, wir benutzen das gar nicht.
Da bin ich immer skeptisch, ja.
Lass uns das nochmal schnell angucken.
Skippen wir mal drüber,
14 Minuten.
Keck Alu-Time.
Microsofts neuer Servicevertrag erlaubt total über...
Okay...
Jetzt geht es schon wieder damit los.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich sehe das,
wahrscheinlich sieht er das überhaupt nicht so,
aber ich sehe das immer...
Was könnte schief gehen?
Ich mach mir schnell einen Alu-Hut und...
Oh, Keck Alu!
Excellent!
So, jetzt bin ich bereit. Microsofts neuer
Servicevertrag erlaubt total Überwachung
aller Nutzer.
Titelt aktuell sehr reißerisch die Webseite
tankappe.info.
Ich habe sehr viele Kommentare und Mails dazu
erhalten, weswegen ich an dieser Stelle ein paar
Details davon analysieren möchte.
Ganz viele Nutzer, mit denen ich diskutiert
habe, benutzen diesen
Artikel als Quelle und
daher wollen wir auch über diesen Artikel reden.
...
Also...
Im Artikel ist die Rede von Machtmissbrauch,
es wird suggeriert, Microsoft arbeite
mit Gestapo-Methoden
und am Ende gibt es natürlich für
all diese Probleme eine einzige
Lösung und die heißt
Linux. Ich habe mir den Artikel...
Ja das ist sicherlich...
ist sicherlich eine Lösung, wenn man
keinen Bock auf Windows hat...
...
Was zur FX?
Aber Leute!
Linux. Ihr wisst es
genau. Welches Linux?
Ich will es jetzt hören, Chat.
Welches Linux?
By the way? Arch Linux.
Der Chat weiß schon Bescheid.
Arch Linux, natürlich. Wenn schon
richtig.
Geht auch vielleicht.
Arch Linux muss es sein. Wenn überhaupt
dann Arch Linux.
By the way.
Ich komme hier nicht zum selben Schluss
wie der Autor. Das sage ich euch ganz
ehrlich. Einerseits auffällig bei
diesem Artikel ist konkret, wie wenig
Beweise der Autor liefert für seine
ziemlich extremen Behauptungen.
Im gesamten Artikel, worin Microsoft
auf Basis des Servicevertrags
vorgeworfen wird, die totale
Überwachung von Nutzern zu ermöglichen,
wird kein... Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich kann euch nichts Stichhaltiges
dazu sagen. Ich habe das selbst nicht gelesen.
Ein einziges Mal, auch nur
ein einziges Wort,
geschweige denn ein Satz, aus dem
Microsoft Servicevertrag zitiert.
Was denkt ihr, woran das liegt?
Ja gut.
Ja gut, okay. Es ist nicht
der Servicevertrag selbst.
Vertragliche Relevanz
für den Nutzer nicht, aber das
interessiert doch eh keinen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als ist es jetzt was,
womit du dann zu Microsoft gehen könntest
und sagen, guck mal, so habe ich das aber nicht unterschrieben.
Theoretisch schon, praktisch nicht.
Aus dem Microsoft Servicevertrag zitiert.
Was denkt ihr, woran das liegt?
Vergleichen wir also die aktuellen
Vorwürfe wirklich mal mit Microsoft.
Der Servicevertrag ist wahrscheinlich
deutlich schwammiger, als das, was auf der
Seite steht. Aber schwammig ist
gerade in solchen Fällen meistens nicht gut.
Hier steht zum Beispiel,
Microsoft nimmt sich damit das Recht
heraus, uns von vorne bis hinten
zu durchleuchten, heißt das Wort.
Ja gut, das haben sie ja jetzt mehr oder weniger
auch schon.
Und als Beweis liefert der Autor
das einzige Zitat vom gesamten Artikel
mit, und das ist auch tatsächlich
das einzige Zitat von Microsoft, und
das lautet,
Daraus folgert der Autor
folgendes.
Also was ich daraus folgern würde, ist,
dass im Zweifelsfall
Microsoft die Sachen, die auf meinem
PC sind, scannt nach
illegal, wie auch immer das bei Microsoft
so definiert ist, oder nach schädlichen
und illegalen Inhalten.
Also das würde ich da rein interpretieren.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, Chat.
Ich würde rein interpretieren, Microsoft kann meinen
kompletten PC scannen, ob sie irgendwas finden, was
ihm nicht passt.
Das heißt, dass alle Inhalte auf unserer Festplatte
und in der Cloud 24 7
automatisch auf bestimmte Keywords
hin untersucht werden.
Ja,
das klingt jetzt sehr ultimativ, wie
er das geschrieben hat, aber
die Interpretation dazu
besteht ja, denke ich, durchaus.
Es klingt scary, aber es
ist faktisch,
kann ich anders sagen, es ist einfach falsch.
Daher sage ich es hier klipp und klar,
das Thema hat nichts mit Windows zu tun,
sondern ausschließlich mit Microsofts
Diensten. Es steht fast
wortwörtlich im ersten Satz des
Servicevertrags, wenn man hier
klickt, dass Windows hier
gar nicht dazu gehört.
Niemand gleicht also eure privaten Fotos
auf eurer Festplatte ab, es geht da
nicht um eure Festplatte, niemand
greift auf eure Fotos zu und vergleicht
sie, selbst der OneDrive-Vergleich
erfolgt technisch gesehen nicht eurer Festplatte.
Auf Keywords und auch nicht visuell,
sondern...
Wie das jetzt letztendlich gemacht wird
und wie es jetzt gerade ausgelegt
wird, ist ja
nicht unbedingt gleich dem, was der Vertrag
eigentlich hergeben würde, oder?
Ich meine,
ich kann auch sagen, hier,
ähm, ich
räume mir das Recht ein,
jeden zu bannen bei mir im Chat
und ich
banne vielleicht nur fünf Leute und nicht alle.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass ich morgen nicht alle banne.
Sondern
basierend auf mathematischen Formeln.
Der Autor erwähnt zwar
in diesem Artikel Windows nicht explizit,
aber er spricht von eurer Festplatte
und daraus wird relativ schnell
klar, was der Autor damit erreichen
will.
Chat, wir müssen das jetzt...
Seht das mal nicht so negativ jetzt.
Ich finde das sogar gut, dass der ein Video
dazu macht und sich den Vertrag angeguckt hat
und das... Ich sehe da nichts
Verwerfliches dran.
Bei mir ist es halt immer nur so,
ich denke, sobald
die, sagen wir mal, sobald die Möglichkeiten geschaffen
sind, muss man davon ausgehen, dass sie
früher oder später auch benutzt werden.
Linux versus OneDrive, sondern
Linux versus Windows. Äpfel und
Birnen, wie man so schön sagt. Aber
jetzt konkret. Ist es auch die Frage,
Playstation oder Xbox?
Was heißt, Microsoft verwendet
Hashes von illegalen Inhalten und gleicht diese
mit jenen Daten ab, die auch...
Das stand ja nicht nur verwendet...
Das stand als Erklärung da.
Im eigentlichen Vertrag stand
doch... Moment, wir merken uns wohl jetzt hier mit
3.24.
Im eigentlichen Vertrag stand doch...
Wortwörtlich im ersten Satz
des Servicevertrags, wenn man
hier klickt, dass Windows...
Äh, bin ich jetzt blöd...
Hier.
Darüber hinaus
setzen wir unsere eigene Technologie
und Klassifizierer
ein, um schädliche Inhalte
zu finden, die über unsere Dienste verbreitet
werden.
Ich mein, ihre Dienste können auch so
Dinger sein wie, was weiß ich,
äh, Windows Defender
oder sowas.
Oder spätestens,
wenn einer irgendwelche VMs in der Cloud
benutzt, oder was auch immer...
Das ist mega schwammig. Das kann
auch im Zweifelsfall wirklich alles sein.
Also ich seh da schon...
Also ich seh's vielleicht nicht so...
Ja, das ist hundertprozentig so,
wie der eine Artikel, aber...
Ich find schon, dass man das durchaus
da reininterpretieren kann.
Und wenn es nicht dein PC ist,
der durchsucht werden kann nach
schädlichen Inhalten, dann ist es auf jeden Fall
die Sache, die du in irgendeinem Cloud-Laufwerk
oder in irgendeinem Office oder sonst wo
liegen hast. Und dass das so ist,
kam ja auch letztens
erst raus, weil...
Ihr erinnert euch noch vielleicht
daran, Mails, die über Outlook verschickt
werden, mit
verschlüsselten ZIP-Archiven
im Anhang, werden versucht
von Microsoft zu analysieren und
zu entschlüsseln.
Das gab es letztens erst
größere Berichterstattung drüber.
Microsoft verwendet
ja, weiß nicht wie
groß, ein Wörterbuch mit Standard-Passwörtern
und versucht angehängte
ZIP-Archive zu entschlüsseln.
Die an der Mail
dranhängen.
Also, wie gesagt, ich denke halt immer nur,
sobald die Möglichkeiten da sind und die eingeräumt
sind, dann werden die früher oder später auch
benutzt.
Ja, und ich meine, guck mal, spätestens die Windows-Suche,
wenn du hier eingibst, keckel.
Ja, dann findet man was auch
immer alles. Jetzt benutzt du einen
Microsoft-Service an der Stelle schon.
Also, das ist alles sehr, sehr
vage, ne?
...meiner OneDrive-Festplatte
gespeichert sind. Was ich auf Microsofts Diensten
speichere, wie wird das denn mit
irgendwelchen Inhalten, illegalen Inhalten
verglichen? Der Autor
spricht konkret von Keywords,
aber er könnte ferner von der Wahrheit
nicht sein. Der Satz beschreibt konkret,
wie Microsoft nach illegalen Inhalten
in OneDrive und seinen anderen Online-Diensten
filtert. Nochmal,
das hat nix mit eurer Festplatte zu tun
und auch nix mit euren Dateien auf eurem
Windows-PC. Hier wird nur
die Basis der Technologie erklärt,
die übrigens nicht eure Fotos scannt oder
durchsucht. Diese Technologie benutzt
sogar Google bei seinen Diensten und auch Facebook
benutzt sie.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ne?
Ob das schon ein Durchsuchen
ist oder nicht.
Letztendlich, wenn man mal wirklich vom
einfachsten Fall ausgeht, ja,
ähm, Bilder werden
wie auch immer
gehasht, teilweise komplett,
wie dem auch sei,
und dann abgeglichen
mit Hashes von Bildern,
die, sag mal, irgendwelche
illegalen, bekannt, sag mal, du musst ja
quasi bekannte, illegale Bilder
nehmen und die hashen
und dann abgleichen. Das Ding ist,
da habe ich vor einer ganzen Weile auch mal
was drüber gelesen, als Apple das
angekündigt hat, in ihrer Cloud
zu scannen, einfach,
DATEI-Hashes wird's
bei Bildern nicht tun.
Das müssen
schon Verfahren sein, um
gewisse,
gewisser, wie soll man
sagen, ein bisschen
breitflächiger
als auf wirklich Bit-Ebene.
Weil wir haben es uns letztens erst zusammen
angeguckt, änderst du ein
Bit in einer Datei, kommt ein komplett
unterschiedlicher Hash raus.
So, und
das willst du ja gerade nicht.
Du komprimierst das
Bild, es ist ein anderer Hash
am Ende.
Du screenshotest
das Bild von einer Webseite,
es hat ein bisschen andere Formate,
ein neuer Hash. Und
das heißt, gerade beim
Thema Inhaltserkennung
brauchst du eine gewisse,
ja, wie kann man das nennen,
also kein bitweise
Hash, sondern etwas, was ein bisschen
breiter, breiter
gefächert ist, also wo du Inhalte
kategorisieren kannst,
nicht rein anhand
1 zu 1 der Bits.
Und da können sich natürlich
schon die ein oder anderen
Fehler,
Fehlerkennungen einschleichen,
ja, die ein oder anderen
Fehler einschleichen, ja. Also,
und dann ist auch das andere
wieder, jetzt
überlegt euch mal,
irgendjemand hat ein Bild
von seinen
Kindern im
Pool.
So, die Kinder sind klein,
die Kinder sind nackig, hat ein Bild von seinen Kindern
im Pool gemacht. Also, die Chance,
dass das auf irgendwelche
Kinderporno
Referenzdinger matcht,
ist
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal so gering.
Und das sind halt so Dinger,
wo man sich dann denkt, ja,
wie geht das dann weiter?
So, guck mal, was das Video macht.
Und sie wurde tatsächlich von
Microsoft selbst entwickelt und
wird auch Strafverfolgungsbehörden
kostenfrei bereitgestellt. Hier ist nur eine
kurze Erklärung dieser Technologie, die sich übrigens
Fotodna nennt und die eigentlich
mathematische Formeln benutzt, um
die Bilder miteinander zu vergleichen. Siehste, siehste,
sind wir schon beim Thema, es sind keine
1 zu 1 Bithashes, deswegen
das funktioniert bei Bildern ja auch nicht.
3% Fehlerquote ist
enorm. Also, ganz
ehrlich, bei 3% Fehlerquote,
wenn ich in
Aufzug steigen müsste und die
sagen, in 3% der Fällen stürzt
der Aufzug ab, ich würde nicht reinsteigen.
3% ist ganz schön viel.
Siehste,
das ist im Prinzip das, was ich auch gerade versucht
habe zu erklären.
Ja, aber da sind wir schon mal
weit weg von, es ist irgendwelche
reine, reinen
Bitweise-Hashes,
sondern du kannst sehr wohl damit
auf gewisse Inhalte von den Sachen,
die du dort in der Cloud gespeichert hast, schließen.
Gab's sogar einen Artikel zu?
Ja, automatisiert das gern, das Microsoft-Spendkunden-Unternehmen.
Das ist halt so,
was ich am Anfang meinte,
sobald du die Möglichkeit dafür
geschaffen hast,
dann wird das auch genutzt
irgendwann, früher oder später.
Also abstrahiert, es wird in einen
mathematischen Hash konvertiert und
dann werden Dateien, die ihr auf eurem OneDrive
habt, auf Basis ihrer Hashes
mit einer Datenbank vermisster Kinder
oder Opfer sexuellen Missbrauchs
verglichen. Hier ist zum Beispiel so ein Hash
von einem Bild und wie das auf... Also, ich
seh das alles enorm skeptisch.
Und dann hat dann irgendeine Polizei
vor der Tür stehen, weil man ein Bild
von seinen Kindern im Pool gemacht hat.
Na toll.
Und dann hat dann die Polizei
das Bild von ihren Kindern
verglichen, sondern nur Hashes.
Damit eine Keyword-basierte Analyse
stattfinden kann, müsste man erstmal
die Objekte auf den Bildern erkennen.
Zum Beispiel Hund, Katze oder Karotte.
Und dies dann eben mit einer Datenbank
von rechtswidrigen Bildern abgleichen.
Das braucht aber extrem viel Rechenleistung,
ist wesentlich unpräziser als das
mathematisch basierte Foto-DNA-Modell
und deswegen sind auch eure Privatfotos
im Regelfall nicht problematisch,
denn dieses System ist genug.
Nein, das hat er doch grad erklärt.
Es geht hier nicht um bitweise einzelne
Einzeldinger. Es geht grade da drum,
Bilder von Kindern zu erkennen,
die unter anderem vermisst sind.
Also, da geht's ja grade nicht drum,
bitweise die einzelnen
Fotos miteinander
zu vergleichen.
Ja, das ist die nächste Frage.
Nachdem die das Originalbild nicht haben,
nachdem die das Originalbild
sich nicht angucken können,
ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das dann läuft,
ob dann irgendjemand, ob dann die Polizei
vor der Tür stehen hast.
Naja, also, wenn das abgeglichen wird
mit den Bildern von vermissten Kindern,
muss ja zumindest in irgendeiner Art und Weise
was erkannt werden,
was sagt, ja, das könnte
das Gesicht
von dem vermissten Kind sein oder nicht.
Wie genau das funktioniert, wissen wir nicht.
Das kann auch sein, dass du
den Strand fotografierst
und das zufälligerweise
ähnlich genug ist zu dem Bild
von einem vermissten Kind.
Also, wie gesagt,
wenn das stimmt, mit den 3%
Fehlerquote, dann ist das enorm viel.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist es eigentlich vollkommen
egal,
es passiert das,
was ja angeblich laut dem Video nicht passiert,
dass deine Bilder nicht
ups, war geil,
äh,
abgeglichen werden.
Das ist eine bescheuerte
Erklärung, was die
dafür benutzen. Das ist im Endeffekt,
irgendeine Erkennungsmöglichkeit,
wo es nicht darauf ankommt,
dass du die Bilder bitweise
miteinander vergleichst,
sondern, dass es eben kein
1 zu 1 bitweise vergleichen ist,
sondern ein, ja,
Inhaltsfragmente
vergleichen,
in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert und was
und ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das überhaupt öffentlich bekannt ist.
Ähm,
es ist zumindest nicht bitweise.
Es ist einfach
zuverlässig, um Force Positives
vermeiden zu können.
Es basiert nämlich, denn dieses System ist
genug zuverlässig, um Force Positives
vermeiden zu können.
Ist das so?
Das ist wesentlich
unpräziser als das mathematisch basierte
Photo DNA Modell und deswegen sind auch eure
Privatfotos im Regelfall nicht problematisch,
denn dieses System ist genug zuverlässig,
um Force Positives vermeiden zu können.
Das heißt, da habe ich meine Zweifel.
Ich meine,
wenn du Fragmente erkennen kannst,
in irgendeiner Art und Weise, wenn du zum Beispiel
darauf Rückschlüsse ziehen kannst, okay,
auf dem Bild könnte eines der, eines
der vermissten Kinder drauf sein.
Natürlich kann das in die Hose
gehen und auch Mist
detekten. Und selbst wenn wir bei
0,1% sind,
ähm, selbst wenn
es wirklich, wirklich viel, viel
geringer wäre, selbst wenn man bei 0,1%
ist, guckt mal,
wie viele Millionen Sachen da verglichen
werden. Ja,
und sicherlich werden dann bei der, bei der
genaueren Überprüfung von denen,
die erkannt werden, die falsch sind,
auch noch einige rausfliegen.
Aber früher oder später
haben Leute Polizei vor der Tür
stehen, die nichts damit zu tun haben.
Also, und selbst
bei Fingerabdrücken, Leute, ihr dürft,
ihr dürft nicht vergessen, Fingerabdrücke werden
und, und, also wurden und werden
ja immer noch als ziemlich gutes,
ja so, Unique,
Unique
Identifikationsmittel, äh,
benutzt. Und selbst Fingerabdrücke
haben gar nicht so,
so selten Kollisionen.
Zwar sehr selten,
aber es kommt durchaus vor. Es gibt,
äh, ich hab da letztens erst was drüber
gelesen, ich weiß nicht, ob man das
Kollisionen überhaupt nennt, ja,
äh, oder Fingerabdrücke,
ähm,
dass Leute,
ja, dass Leute
teilweise so, ohne, also Leute nicht mit
einander verwandt sind,
so ähnliche Fingerabdrücke haben können,
dass die, ähm,
beispielsweise den Finger scannen können,
an einem, ja,
Eingang zu einem Rechenzentrum oder so, und der akzeptiert
werden würde. Weil das Ding ist halt,
suchst du
jemand, der
Fingerabdrücke hat, also, glücklicherweise ist es
nicht ganz so schlimm in, in, in
so Verdachtsfällen, weil
suchst du jemand, der exakt
zu diesem Fingerabdruck passt, ist es natürlich enorm
schwierig, einen zu finden.
Suchst du einfach nur zwei Leute, die einen
ähnlich genügend Fingerabdruck
haben, wirst du auf jeden Fall
genug finden. Ja, also
so Fingerabdruck-Kollisionen kommen öfters vor,
als man denkt.
Nicht, dass Force Positives ausgeschlossen sind
und, dass Leute bereits wegen eines
Fehlers dieses Systems ihre Accounts
verloren haben. Das stimmt. Ja. Aber,
ich wollte hier nur klarstellen, wie genau dieser
Abgleich funktioniert, und er
bezieht sich tatsächlich nur darauf, was
ihr auf OneDrive und Outlook oder Skype rumsendet
und eben nicht, was auf euren
Windows-Festplatte drauf ist.
Es werden hier noch ein paar andere Punkte
Mag jetzt so sein,
sollte der Vertrag das
ermöglichen, oder sollte
das vielleicht nicht jetzt schon, man weiß ja nie,
wird das früher oder später auch gemacht.
...gebracht, darunter wird
die neue Meldefunktion als
Einladung zur Denunzierung
bezeichnet. Ja, du bringst ein nices T-Shirt.
Der Autor suggeriert hier, man
könnte unliebsame Zeitgenossen,
also eure Feinde,
sozusagen, durch Meldung ihres
Accounts Ärger bereiten.
Das klingt doch sehr nach Gestapo,
findet ihr nicht?
Was hier konkret gemeint sein dürfte,
ist sehr wahrscheinlich der Punkt 4
Absatz B2 der Richtlinien. Ja, das finde ich
im Originalartikel dann aber auch ein bisschen
schwammig. Ich mein,
wenn du sowas behauptest, solltest du ja mal
zumindest die Stelle von diesem Servicevertrag
verlinken können oder zitieren können,
der dich zu dieser Annahme
bringt. Richtlinien, ich sag
wahrscheinlich, denn im Artikel wird
keine einzige dieser Richtlinien
konkret genannt. Ja, na gut,
willkommen im Club, solche Richtlinien
werden ja überall, guckt euch Twitch an
oder sonstige Plattformen, die sind ja überall immer super
schwammig. Lesen wir das erstmal
gemeinsam. Hier steht, sie können
bedenkliche Inhalte oder Verhaltensweisen,
die gegen unseren Verhaltenskodex
verstoßen, hier melden.
Microsoft hat also jetzt
eine Meldefunktion, sodass
ihr einen Account bei Microsoft melden
könnt, wenn dieser euch Spam,
Pornografie einer bestimmten kriminellen
Art oder andere
laut Geschäftsbedingungen inkorrekte
Inhalte per Mail schickt oder per Skype
zum Beispiel oder euch einen Freigabelink
auf... Das gibt, diese
Meldefunktion gibt es, gibt es ja
bei nahezu jeder Plattform und bei nahezu
jeder Plattform wurde die auch schon missbraucht.
Weil, das
gucken sich ja erstmal gar keine Leute an,
wenn genug Meldungen, zum Beispiel
auf YouTube, hat man es ja schon öfters gesehen,
dass Videos gelöscht werden, teilweise Accounts
suspendiert werden, weil
einfach nur in genug, in kurz
genugem Abstand, genug Leute
was reported haben. Ja,
oftmals wird das im Nachhinein
wieder aufgehoben, aber
oftmals, und das hat man auch gerade im Bereich
tja, so Security-Videos
schon gesehen, hat der Typ, der sich
das auf YouTube anguckt, gar keinen Plan
von dem, was er sich anguckt und sagt
Oh ja, natürlich, das
ist ein Hacking-Video, böser Inhalt.
Es wurde auf nahezu jeder Plattform schon missbraucht,
das Meldesystem. Trotzdem,
denke ich, ist es wichtig, dass es ein Meldesystem
gibt. Das ist das, da die Balance
zu finden, ist sehr
kostenintensiv wahrscheinlich für den Anbieter.
OneDrive dazu schickt.
Unfassbar, oder? Wo kommen wir
denn dahin, wenn man jetzt auch online
Leute melden kann?
Was, andere Dienste wie Facebook,
Reddit und Dropbox und Google haben ebenfalls
Geschäftsbedingungen und dort kann man auch
Leute wegen Verstößen
melden?
Also, dass es die Funktion gibt, finde ich nicht schlimm,
aber dass die Funktion missbraucht werden kann, hat
man oft genug gesehen.
Echt nur Twitter noch geblieben als einziger
freier Ort. Twitter hat das auch.
Auf Twitter kriegst du aber witzigerweise
immer so eine Meldung danach, so
wir wurden
darauf hingewiesen, dass das hier illegale Inhalte
sind. Eine Prüfung hat ergeben, die Inhalte sind nicht
illegal. Wo man noch
Und noch ein Punkt, der in diesem Artikel
thematisiert wird, betrifft den neuen
Verhaltenskodex oder die Verhaltensregeln,
die Microsoft definiert.
Diese wurden implementiert, weil
Microsoft erst kürzlich künstliche Intelligenz
zu seinen Diensten hinzugefügt hat.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, was ich im neuen Windows Update nicht
benutzen werde. Und da hat man für seine,
für diese Dienste eben ein paar
Verhaltensregeln definiert.
Wer nur den ersten Punkt liest, wobei ich
bezweifle, dass der Autor auch das überhaupt
gemacht hat, könnte diese als
vage erachten, aber es ist hier
doch recht klar definiert, was Microsoft
als unrechtmäßige Handlungen
ansieht. Es sind hauptsächlich
Sachen, womit ihr sehr wahrscheinlich
gegen geltendes deutsches Recht
verstoßen würdet, aber wer
schert sich schon um das Gesetz.
Ich lasse mir keinen Verhaltenskodex
vorschreiben, schreibt der Autor auf seiner
Seite. Der geht auch immer aus Prinzip
bei rot über die Ampel.
Kurz zusammengefasst, damit ich das jetzt nicht
alles vorlesen muss, aber wir werden die
jeweiligen Absätze von den richtigen
Also, solche Verhaltenssachen
gibt es ja auf jeder Seite, gibt es auf Twitch ja auch.
Bei Twitch ist eher das Problem, dass es immer mal
so, mal so alles ausgelegt wird.
Ja, dass es jetzt sowas
gibt, pff, das ist groß
juckt, weiß nicht.
Richtlinien im Video herzeigen und zitieren
und ihr werdet sie auch unten in der Videobeschreibung
verlinkt finden. Man soll
laut dem neuen
Verhaltenskodex keine Inhalte
teilen oder generieren, die dazu gedacht sind
Kindern zu schaden. Man darf keinen
Spam versenden, keine betrügerischen Handlungen
durchführen und Microsoft verbietet
auch seine künstliche Intelligenz zu
reverse-engineeren oder zu jail-breaken,
um diese beispielsweise zur Erstellung
von Malware zu kriegen.
Microsoft hat gewisse Barrieren
implementiert, was ChatGPT und
deren Bildgeneratoren und so weiter
können, dürfen und was
eben nicht. Zum Beispiel
soll es keine Viren herstellen oder
Captures lösen, obwohl es
das easy-peasy könnte.
Microsoft sagt, man wird Nutzer
davon ausschließen, von seinen Diensten,
die aktiv versuchen, diese Dienste zu
manipulieren oder für potenziell
unlautere oder gefährliche Zwecke
zu benutzen. Der einzige Kritikpunkt,
den ich jetzt konkret
Ja, also das hat ja so gut wie jeder
Seite.
Punkt 3, Absatz 8 des Servicevertrags.
Das lese ich euch ganz kurz vor. Da steht
Verletzen Sie nicht die Rechte anderer,
zum Beispiel durch unbefugtes Teilen von
urheberrechtlich geschützter Musik oder
anderen urheberrechtlich geschützten Materialien
und so weiter, bei der Nutzung der Dienste.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach ein Problem.
Microsoft macht nämlich
euch dafür verantwortlich,
wenn ihr deren Bildgenerator nutzt
und dieser ein Foto ausschickt.
Naja, das macht Microsoft, dass sie keine Horde
von Anwälten vor der Tür stehen haben. Praktisch passieren
sie dann trotzdem nichts.
Das eine Urheberrechtsverletzung darstellt.
Also, wenn ihr dieses Bild dann kommerziell verwendet,
zum Beispiel auf der Facebook-Seite eurer Pizzeria.
Das Problem ist,
ihr könnt als Nutzer eigentlich gar nicht wissen,
mit welchem Material das
AI-Modell trainiert wurde und
zu beweisen, ob die AI das Werk einer anderen
Person tatsächlich genutzt hat,
ist schwierig für den Nutzer,
wenn nicht sogar ganz unmöglich.
Aber, das ist schon sehr weit
weg von den Vorwürfen, die wir in diesem
Artikel formuliert haben und
also, ich denke mal, der Artikel ist
sehr, sagen wir mal so,
in die eine Richtung übertrieben.
Ich finde, das Video ist
vielleicht auch ein bisschen, schwingt dann
doch ein bisschen zu sehr in die andere Richtung aus.
Ich denke, man muss das einfach realistisch sehen,
sobald, wie ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen,
sobald Möglichkeiten da sind, sobald Möglichkeiten
geschaffen sind, was zu machen,
früher oder später wird es auch gemacht.
... sei aber trotzdem hier dazu erwähnt.
Also, sind Microsofts neue Nutzungsbedingungen
dazu gemacht, um die Totalüberwachung
aller Nutzer zu ermöglichen?
Nein.
Die Frage ist nicht, wurden sie
dazu mit der Absicht gemacht, sondern
geben sie es her.
... gewissen Punkten vage oder gar problematisch?
Für gewisse Nutzer ja.
Wer die Bing AI benutzen will, um
Malware zu programmieren oder illegale
Inhalte zu generieren, die mit
Kindern zu tun haben, der könnte
seinen Microsoft Account relativ schnell verlieren.
Wer seine Outlook E-Mail
benutzt, um anderen Nutzern Spam
zu schicken, der könnte seinen
Microsoft Account verlieren. Und wer glaubt,
er könnte den Bing Bildgenerator
benutzen, um ein Foto von Jessica Alba
zu kreieren, wie sie in den leckeren
Kebab eures Dönerladens beißt
und diesen dann als Facebook
Post zu verwenden, der könnte
Post bekommen von ihren Anwälten und
Microsoft wird euch nicht zu Hilfe
eilen. Das steht so
in den AGBs.
Ich stimme dem übrigens zu, dass wir uns
von den Anbietern unserer Dienste
nicht alles gefallen lassen sollten. Und Kritik
ist insbesondere angebracht, wenn
Kinderschutz als Vorwand benutzt wird.
Wenn man Spam über sein Bing Account schickt,
die Leute, denen der Account übernommen
wurde von irgendwelchen anderen Leuten,
also ich denke nicht, dass jemand absichtlich
Spam wissentlich über sein Bing Account
verschickt, aber es kommt jetzt
in der Vergangenheit auch, also ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr das auch schon mal hattet, dass ihr von
Leuten oder von Absenderadressen, die ihr
eigentlich kennt, schon mal
Spam bekommen habt.
Dass es natürlich besonders tückig ist,
je nachdem wie gut er ist, weil du Leute kennst
und dann kommt meistens im Nachhinein raus,
und den hat er einfach jahrelang nicht benutzt
und irgendwie hat sich
einer Zugang zum Account verschafft und
verschickt damit jetzt Spam.
...daten durchsuchbar zu machen und diese beispielsweise
für Werbezwecke dann zu verwenden.
Oder wenn Jugendschutz ein Vorwand ist
für strategische Überlegungen,
wie das zum Beispiel bei Sony und dem
Minecraft Crossplay der Fall war.
Aber die Wahrheit ist,
bei der News rund um die aktuellen
Nutzungsbedingungen von Microsofts
Diensten, da wird viel übertrieben.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, die Leute, die
weiter Windows, Office 365,
Teams und Microsoft Services verwenden
wollen, schräg schräg müssen,
kommen da eh nicht drum herum.
...eine Verbindung mit Windows hergestellt,
wo sie sie gar nicht gibt
und es werden bewusste Tatsachen
verstellt oder aus dem Kontext gerissen
Ah, der Originalartikel erscheint
mir auch etwas übertrieben.
Kann man so machen, ist aber
nicht wirklich großartige journalistische
Praxis und es scheidet ehrlich gesagt
der guten Sache mehr, als es ihr nutzt.
Für alles, was ich in diesem Video sage,
findet ihr unten die Links in der Beschreibung
aufgeführt und wir haben natürlich auch
einen Artikel geschrieben, der etwas näher
auf das Thema eingeht, damit das hier
im Video nicht zu lange wird.
Oder glaubt ihr, ich habe Spaß daran,
Serviceverträge und AGBs zu lesen?
Es liegt mir hier außerdem fern,
den Verteidiger von Microsoft zu spielen
und wer behauptet, ich sei ein bezahlter
Microsoft-Chill, der soll doch mal mein
MacBook Pro Review gucken oder den
Servicevertrag einfach selbst lesen.
Ich habe objektiv alle Fakten auf den Tisch
gelegt und es ist alles unten,
mit Links zu den Quellen belegt,
wie Armin Siehausen.
Ich finde das gut.
Wie gesagt, vielleicht gerade im ersten Teil
ein bisschen zu pro das Ganze
oder vielleicht ein bisschen zu lasch
das ausgelegt, aber
bei manchen Sachen gebe ich ihm ja auch recht.
Manche sind im Originalartikel, klingt mir auch
etwas sehr weit an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
Reale Probleme
dieses neuen Servicevertrags an
und ich decke Probleme, aber auch Mythen
rund um Windows schon seit
mehr als 10 Jahren hier auf
Es gibt Probleme
und die Sache mit den
Accountsperrungen ist tatsächlich
ein wirklich ernsthaftes Thema, das ich schon seit
Jahren aktiv recherchiere und womit
ich mich noch näher befassen werde in Zukunft.
Dr. Windows.
Wer mir dabei helfen möchte
und seinen Microsoft Account gesperrt
bekommen hat, der kann gerne über den
Link in der Videobeschreibung bei der Recherche
helfen. Accountsperrungen sind
in der heutigen Zeit ein enormes
Problem, vor allem weil wir
für viele Dinge unseres digitalen
Lebens auf einen Anbieter setzen,
wo wir dann all unsere Fotos, Spiele, Filme
usw. gespeichert haben.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich in ganz
vielen Sachen einer Meinung mit dem Autor
hier, aber es hilft der Sache
nicht, wenn man nicht objektiv mit
dem Thema umgeht und falsche Vorwürfe
formt. Das ist immer schwierig, ich meine
die wenigsten Leute
sind bei egal welchem Thema
so immer 100% objektiv.
Ein bisschen spielt ja immer noch mit rein, was du selbst so
im Kopf hast. Womit man
im Endeffekt nur Nutzer aufhetzt gegen...
Da muss man sich schon echt Mühe geben.
... bei Unternehmen, aber diese Kunden
dann nicht wirklich objektive
Argumente mitgibt, sondern hauptsächlich
Polemik. Das will ich hier verhindern
und ich wünsche mir daher eine faktenbasierte
Diskussion, wie wir auch
das bei anderen Themen hier praktizieren
und wir wollen hier
Microsoft tatsächlich faktenbasiert
analysieren auf diesem Channel.
So, das war's
dann auch schon von mir und von diesem Video
über Microsoft... Das fällt manchen Leuten allgemein
sehr schwer.
Wie viele YouTube Tabs? Wieso so viele
sind das doch gar nicht? Guck mal, ich habe hier noch ein paar mehr.
Aber hier habe ich gerade nicht so viele.
Ich kriege langsam
richtig Hunger, Leute.
Warum? Ach, weil Zeitumstellung.
Weil jetzt
eigentlich schon 12.30 Uhr
ist, kann das sein? 12.13 Uhr
kann das sein?
War es gestern 12.30 Uhr?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken mit Zeitumstellung in welche
Richtung. Oder ist es
erst heute Nacht? Wann ist denn das?
Oder war das schon?
Nee, das...
Ach, das ist erst.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das war jetzt.
Das war jetzt. Das war auf der Nacht von Samstag
auf Sonntag.
Das ist auch so pepega-Kram.
Erinnert ihr euch noch daran,
dass vor 4, 5 Jahren oder so
das mal so eine Umfrage gab,
ob die Zeitumstellung
nicht abgeschafft werden soll und ein
Großteil der Bevölkerung hat gesagt, ja, weg mit
dem Scheiß. Und danach hat man sich einfach
gedacht, okay, wir ignorieren das jetzt.
Wir haben mal eine Umfrage gemacht, aber wir ignorieren das jetzt.
Wir machen nix.
Gucken wir mal. EU-Zeitumstellung.
Was es da zu Neues gibt.
2018 war das sogar schon.
Die können sich noch nicht einigen.
Okay, EU-Sachen
in einer Nussschale quasi.
Das ist doch gefühlt immer so.
Ja, gar nicht, oder?
Der NTP-Server
hat doch damit gar nichts zu tun.
Ist es nicht so, dass dein Client sagt, was
er... Also, dass die NTP-Zeit
von einem Client
dann quasi umgerechnet wird in
lokale Zeit?
Der NTP-Server hat doch, glaube ich, mit der
Zeitzone und so gar nichts groß zu tun.
Oder? Ich habe mich damit nie so im
Detail beschäftigt.
Also musst du einfach gar
nichts machen an deinem NTP-Server.
By the way, wie hast du
den gemacht? Ich habe auch mal
just for fun einen ESP32
NTP-Server gebaut mit einem
GPS-Empfänger.
GPS-Zeit geholt und
dann... Aber ich habe das nie benutzt. War einfach
nur just for fun, um zu gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Ach, per Internet.
Ja, das ist ja easy.
Dann brauchst du auch kein ESP32
dafür. So, haben wir noch
irgendwas, was wir uns angucken können?
Was ist das?
Oh, OKS, Alter, was?
Wieso meine Fachinformatik-Abschlussprüfung
eine Katastrophe war?
22 Minuten, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken. Ich habe Hunger.
Hunger AF habe ich.
Ich würde mir tatsächlich mal
das hier angucken am Anfang.
Zumindest YouTubes neue Adblock-Strategie.
Und was das bedeutet.
Gucken was Morpheus dazu sagt. Mal gespannt.
YouTube hat neue Adblock-Blocker.
Mittlerweile könnt ihr
drei YouTube-Videos mit Adblocker schauen
und anschließend geht nichts mehr.
Und ja, damit ist YouTube nicht ganz
alleine. Es gab und gibt
zahlreiche Websites, die euch
nicht reinlassen, wenn ihr ein Ad...
Habe ich das auch schon?
Ich hatte bis jetzt das Problem noch nicht.
Also auch mit meinem
Browser, wo ich nicht
eingeloggt bin.
Ach, die Musik ist an, ja.
Auch mit dem Browser, wo ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Guckt mal Leute, wir haben heute total viele
YouTube-Videos geguckt.
Und es kam nichts.
...Adblocker hat.
Oder ist uBlock Origin einfach
...ein riesiges Banner,
dass ihr den Adblocker deaktivieren sollt
oder sie laden tatsächlich den Inhalt
einfach gar nicht mehr.
Und das ist aus...
Das wird bestimmt wieder nur
tief ausgerollt.
Sicherheitsperspektive nicht ganz
unproblematisch. Denn YouTube oder Google
geben nicht annähernd so viel Effekt
darauf, dass die Werbung, die sie euch zeigen
auch wirklich gut ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich gebe bei Werbung prinzipiell davon aus,
dass es Bullshit ist.
Es gab sehr lange die berühmte
Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Werbung, die euch natürlich
Geldscheine.
Im Endeffekt ist das Scam und wird selbst
mit Meldung nicht
immer entfernt.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
jetzt musst du bei ApoRed auf den Channel
und kriegst für irgendwelche komischen Trading-Gruppen
in Dubai Werbung, ohne Werbung
gekennzeichnet zu sein.
Natürlich gab es auf Google
auch Werbung für die berühmte
Fake-Chat-GPT-App, die eure Login-Daten
gestohlen haben.
Im Video zum Malvertising haben wir darüber
ausführlich gesprochen.
Werbung ist ein nicht zu verachtender Angriffsvektor,
wenn man sich nicht gut darum kümmert,
wer werben darf.
Man muss sich auch anschauen, wie viele Daten
für personalisierte Werbung gesammelt werden.
Aber klar ist eben auch, Werbung
für die Finanzierung von Inhalten
ist essentiell für viele.
Viele greifen also eigentlich auch
aus Sicherheitsgründen zu einem
Adblocker.
Aber das geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Zumindest nicht auf YouTube.
Was Google angeht, da kümmern wir uns am Ende drum.
Denn YouTube ist sich
so sicher, dass es keine alternativen
Videoportale gibt, zu denen man
als User wechseln kann.
Also lasst uns kurz darüber sprechen,
was da eigentlich passiert.
Auch aus einer technischen Perspektive.
Denn das Ganze...
Erinnert ihr euch noch daran, dass es
vor Jahren mal
diese Sache auf YouTube gab, dass
als Werbung
Videos geschaltet wurden,
die halt auch
geschaltet wurden, die halt auch als
normale Videos veröffentlicht wurden.
Und da hatte ich wirklich mal, ich hatte mal
irgendwann, weil das gerade jemand
geschrieben hat, ich hatte mal irgendwann
als Werbung auch irgendwie so ein
45-Minuten-Let's Play.
Da habe ich auch gedacht,
hä? Das ist doch nicht das
Video, was du gerade angemacht hast.
Dann habe ich erst gecheckt, dass das Werbung ist.
Das ist aber schon
lange her. Da hatte ich irgendwie so
ein 45-Minuten-Let's Play als Werbung.
Das gesamte
Werbungsgame ändern. Und wir wissen alle,
Ads power the Internet.
Ich werde euch jetzt nicht sagen, dass YouTuber
nur mit YouTube-Werbung überleben
können. Das stimmt schon lange nicht mehr.
Wir müssen uns eigentlich meist selbst um
Sponsoren kümmern. Das ist richtig. Ganz
ehrlich, Werbeeinnahmen
auf YouTube ist wahrscheinlich bei allen,
die das
semi-professionell schon machen
und bei den Profis,
die das komplett hauptberuflich
professionell machen, ganz
was anderes. Reine
YouTube-Adsense-Werbung dürfte wahrscheinlich
wirklich den kleinsten Teil
oder eines der kleinsten
Positionen, was Money-Einnahme
angeht, ausmachen.
... oder Millionen Aufrufe machen.
Deswegen vielen Dank an
GetInIT, dass sie auch dieses Video,
den Kanal und die Academy
damit unterstützen. GetInIT
veranstaltet am Donnerstag den...
Leute, ich habe so krass Hunger.
Dabei ist es erst 11.21 Uhr.
... 26. Oktober
wieder die Job.io. Die Job.io
ist eine kostenlose Jobmesse mit spannenden
Talks, wie auch meinem.
Ich freue mich auch hier wieder den Talk
um 14 Uhr zur Eröffnung halten
zu dürfen. Dieses Mal geht
es um IT-Consulting.
Einen Jobbereich, der für viele, glaube
ich, sehr spannend sein wird. Unter
anderem gelten wir IT-Sicherheitsberater
auch als IT-Consultant
...
Ich skippe jetzt mal die Werbung.
... funktioniert das aber natürlich
fundamental anders als bei
YouTube oder Google Werbung.
Die kann sich jeder ohne
persönliche Absprache auf die Werbung holen.
Das ist bei meinen Sponsoren anders. Im Normalfall
passiert also folgendes.
Man integriert als Website-Betreiber
ein kleines JavaScript
auf seiner Webseite. Bei einer bestimmten
Interaktion oder einfach
beim Laden der gesamten Webseite
wird dann die Werbung geladen und...
Ja gut, das war ja bisher auch so.
Es war auf Twitch ursprünglich
auch so, dass
Werbung ausgeliefert wurde
und Content, also dass Werbung und Content
getrennt ausgeliefert wurden.
Auf Twitch ist es schon eine Weile so,
dass Content und Werbung
zumindest von
den gleichen Servern aus ausgeliefert werden.
Deswegen funktionieren DNS-Blocker nicht mehr.
Und spätestens, wenn Werbung
in den Video-Stream,
der ausgeliefert wird,
rein-encoded wird,
dann hast du eh verloren mit Werbung-Skippen.
Zum Beispiel abgespielt.
AKA, ihr klickt auf
Abspielen bei YouTube und
die Werbung wird abgespielt.
Aber das ist so schwierig, weil das halt aus
sehr hohem Rechenaufwand bedeutet.
Du musst ja für jeden Viewer quasi
den Werbeblock des Anfangs
des Videos re-encoden.
Das ist nicht so ohne weiteres möglich,
weil die Werbung ja auch anders
ist für jeden
Viewer. Oder potenziell anders ist
für jeden Viewer.
Doch, dann kannst du drüber skippen.
Ja gut, je nachdem, was sie
für den Player noch eingebaut haben.
Ist die Werbung fertig, wird das Video
selbst abgespielt.
Aber kann man das nicht einfach
nicht laden?
Spannend, dass du fragst. Das ist absolut
richtig. Ich kann ganz einfach
einzelne JavaScripte
nicht laden. Zum Beispiel kann ich einfach
ads.js blockieren
und einfach ignorieren,
dass sie überhaupt da sein soll. Damit
war tatsächlich der erste
Adblocker geboren.
Alternativ könnt ihr übrigens natürlich auch
einfach den Container für die Werbung
blockieren, in die das immer
reingeschubst wird. Also hier zum Beispiel
blockiere ich zwar keine Google Werbung,
aber die Werbung für Spiegel Plus.
Das heißt in dem Fall... Direkt melden
Hacker-Content. Der Container
oder das Skript... Eindeutig
Hacker-Content, Leute.
...werden einfach nicht geladen
oder nicht angezeigt. Das ist
auch durchaus sinnvoll, denn es gibt
auch andere JavaScripts, die man einfach
nicht zulassen möchte. Muss nicht unbedingt
Werbung sein. Stellt euch vor, da hat
jemand einfach einen JavaScript auf
eurer Website am Laufen.
Das ihr nicht mal kontrollieren könnt.
Da gehört wirklich
viel Vertrauen dazu. Könnte ja beispielsweise
eine Mailware sein, die ihr
euren Nutzern als Website-Betreiber
anzeigt. Naja.
Google und Facebook und Co. genießen
natürlich zum Glück dieses Vertrauen.
Und selbstverständlich kann eine
Website erkennen, dass der
Container von euch entfernt wurde
und ihn dann einfach wieder
reaktivieren. Dann spricht
man von Ad Reinsertion.
Also Werbung
wieder einfügen. Wusste bis jetzt nicht,
dass es dafür ein extra Wort gibt.
Und dann kann natürlich die wieder eingefügte
Werbung auch wieder entfernt werden
und so weiter und so fort.
Aha, aber wie genau kann ich
jetzt dieses Blockieren in einer
mobilen App durchführen?
Naja, leider gar nicht. Deswegen
gibt es auch keine direkten Adblocker
für die eigentliche YouTube App.
Bei Android hast du den Vorteil,
da gibt es dann solche Dinger wie
wir nehmen die offizielle YouTube
APK, dekompilieren die,
bauen einen Adblocker ein und
repackagen sie neu und solche Dinger.
Aber ne, Pi-Hole bringt dir
nix an der Stelle.
An der Stelle bringt dir das vielleicht
noch ein bisschen was, je nachdem von wo
was ausgeliefert wird, aber bei den
neuesten Tricks bringt dir das nix mehr.
Was es aber gibt, sind
externe Tools, die den
kompletten Netzwerkverkehr
verändern. Und hier geht's jetzt in
das nächste Level. Ein Beispiel hier
ist etwa das Pi-Hole. Läuft
auf einem Raspberry Pi und ist eine Art
Netzwerk-Gateway. Ihr könnt euch
das quasi wie einen zusätzlichen Router
vorstellen. Alles, was über das
Internet geht, kommt
erstmal durch den Pi-Hole.
Macht Pi-Hole mittlerweile mehr als DNS
Sachen einfach nicht auflösen?
Ich hab das schon lange nicht mehr benutzt.
...durch und wird dort
gewaschen. Manche Sachen werden
also zwar von der Website oder der App
angefordert, kommen aber einfach
nie an, weil sie im Pi-Hole
blockiert werden. Man kann beispielsweise in
den Pi-Hole einstellen, dass die
Domain-Ads.com einfach komplett verschluckt wird.
Oder man lässt einfach einzelne
Bilder nicht zu. Dann werden die zwar
versucht zu laden, kommen
aber einfach nicht an. Und da die
Webseite oder App weiterhin funktionieren möchte,
ignoriert sie das halt einfach.
Ein anderer Ansatz ist
eine externe App. Sagen wir,
ihr veröffentlicht die App YouTube
Ad Free. Diese
App sieht dann zum Beispiel exakt
so aus wie YouTube und kann
alles, was YouTube kann, aber
sie zeigt nicht YouTube, sondern
sie lädt die Videos von der YouTube
Programmierschnittstelle direkt
und zeigt die euch direkt an.
Ohne, dass sie die Werbung dazu
auch abfragt. Das lässt sich
aber YouTube normalerweise sehr, sehr gut
bezahlen und die App müsste sich dann
irgendwie anders drum kümmern, anschaffen
zu gehen.
Und sind wir mal ehrlich, wenn eine
Website etwas dagegen tun möchte,
ist es wirklich kein Problem, Nutzer
auszusperren. Lasst uns mal kurz durch
die Adblock-Möglichkeiten und
deren Gegenmaßnahmen gehen.
Wird ein Skript...
Unter iPhones wird es ja zunehmend schwieriger.
Unter Android kannst du glücklicherweise ordentlich
sideloaden, was
bei iOS so ohne weiteres
zumindest komfort... Naja,
sideloadete Apps fliegen
bei iOS ja runter, nach glaube ich
5 Tagen oder so.
Nicht geladen. Kann ich eine Warnung anzeigen
oder den Nutzer einfach zum Verlassen der Seite
zwingen, indem ich das mit einem anderen
Skript einfach überprüfe?
Dasselbe gilt natürlich, wenn der Container,
der meine Werbung anzeigen sollte,
plötzlich leer ist. Das nennt sich
Resource Baiting. Wenn die
Ressource nicht da ist,
dann sperre ich den Nutzer zum Beispiel aus.
Das kann ich über JavaScript machen
und sogar das veränderte...
Das machen aber viele Seiten nicht,
weil es ihnen
trotzdem wichtig ist, User zu haben.
...
kann ich mit JavaScript überprüfen.
Und sie halt
irrelevant werden, wenn alle Leute
abhauen. Deswegen denke ich,
kalkulieren sogar sehr viele Seiten schon damit,
dass die Werbung nur auf den Bruchteil
der Endgeräte überhaupt ankommt.
...
JavaScript blockieren, dass das
prüft, ob das Zeug blockiert
wurde. Nun, das ist
erweitertes Adblock-Blocking
und hier wird's entspannt.
Ihr seht schon, das hat sich über die letzten
paar Jahre immer mehr hochgeschaukelt und wurde
immer extremer.
Adblock-Blocker-Blocker sind
sogar seit einigen Jahren der Standard.
Man blockiert...
Adblock-Blocker-Blocker, Alter!
... also Skripte, die erkennen,
ob wir Ads blockieren,
um die Ads blockieren zu können.
Okay?
YouTube hat ein gewaltiges Interesse daran,
dass ihr Inhalte schaut. Aber YouTube hat
für längere Videos eine gewisse
Marktmacht. Und wenn ihr Inhalte schaut,
geht es YouTube nicht unbedingt darum,
dass ihr die Inhalte schaut,
sondern nur die Werbung. Denn
die bringt Geld ein. Deswegen werden
nicht ganz so werbefreundliche Videos...
Da muss ich sagen,
ich glaube, dass es YouTube
nicht unbedingt
nur darum geht, dass man Werbung guckt,
sondern eben auch
die Plattform möchte
auch die Zeit
der Leute binden.
Natürlich, im Endeffekt, je mehr
du guckst, je mehr Werbung guckst du, klar.
Aber umso weniger
Zeit kannst du auf anderen Webseiten verbringen.
Das spielt da auch noch ein bisschen mit rein.
Aber sicherlich.
Es ist ein bisschen wie in irgendeinem Kaufhaus,
die dann ein Restaurant
haben und irgendwelche
Ecken zum Abchillen und so.
Die wissen auch, dass so Verweildauer
im Kaufhaus ganz wichtig ist dafür,
weil umso länger du da bist, umso
mehr kaufst du potenziell.
Bei YouTube guckst du halt Werbung.
Herr King, nur sehr
spärlich auf eure Startseite befördert.
Und ja, das macht durchaus
etwas aus. Denn über 70% von euch
schauen über diese Startseite
YouTube.
Deswegen werden nicht ganz so
werbefreundliche Videos
nur sehr spärlich auf
eure Startseite befördert.
Und ja, das macht durchaus etwas aus.
Denn über 70% von euch schauen
über diese Startseite YouTube.
Ja klar, der Abo-Feed ist ja auch nicht mehr usable.
... entscheidet also, welches Video
gesehen wird, was manche Kanäle
wie auch meinen, ein wenig in
seiner Freiheit einschränkt.
Prima.
Aber natürlich sind zum wahrscheinlichsten
Inhalte, who cares?
Also hat YouTube eigentlich auch kein
besonders großes Interesse an den Leuten,
die keine Werbung sehen.
Denn die kosten YouTube Geld
und bringen nichts ein.
Und damit kann die neue Strategie
Ausschluss von denen,
die einen AdBlocker benutzen.
Das war davor tatsächlich
kein Thema. YouTube macht das
allerdings schwieriger als andere Webseiten.
Die wird minimiert, optimiert, live verändert und vor allem werden Werbevideos nicht von einer fremden Domain geladen, sondern sind selbst nur YouTube-Videos.
Ich kann zum Beispiel ganz einfach eines meiner eigenen Videos zu einem Werbevideo machen.
Dann seht ihr dieses Video, das eigentlich ein normales YouTube-Video ist, als Werbung vor anderen Videos.
Das hat eine spannende Implikation.
Woher soll mein Adblocker wissen, dass jetzt das eine Video gesperrt werden soll, weil Werbung, und das andere nicht?
An diesem Mechanismus scheitern auch schon einige Adblocker von Browsern übrigens.
Der einzige Adblocker, der zumindest manchmal funktioniert, ist aktuell uBlock Origin.
Und deshalb habe ich mir mal angesehen, was der eigentlich so genau macht.
Oh, jetzt wird's pfeifert.
Im Grunde ist auch deren Ansatz ziemlich fehleranfällig und führt häufig dazu,
dass etwas gar nicht funktioniert.
Ihr könnt viele andere Addons nicht mehr nutzen und auch nicht stacken und müsst immer mal wieder auch selbst aktiv werden.
Sie blockieren aber im Grunde nicht stacken und
Die Leute immer, wie die da irgendwelche...
Über die User könnte ich mich immer aufregen.
Ach, Moment, es geht um Adblock Plus.
Ja gut, Adblock Plus ist auch wirklich fragwürdig.
... ja auch selbst aktiv werden.
Sie blockieren aber im Grunde auch nur einige Netzwerke.
Netzwerk-Requests, wie das auch der Pi-Hole macht.
Sie blockieren einige Elemente auf der Webseite und einige Skripte, die geladen werden.
Das wird allerdings zunehmend schwieriger und es gibt einen Punkt, ab dem niemand mehr etwas tun kann.
YouTube ändert derzeit seine Skripte für Werbung und die Orte, wo die Werbung liegt,
zweimal am Tag, schreiben sie zumindest.
Krass.
Die werden dann dynamisch geladen und das passiert wahrscheinlich voll automatisch auf YouTube-Seite.
Jedes Mal, wenn das passiert, muss allerdings beim Adblocker,
ein neuer Eintrag hinterlegt werden, der sagt, das ist Werbung und das dann blockiert.
YouTube muss also eigentlich dafür nicht wirklich was tun und damit haben wir eine Asymmetrie im Aufwand.
YouTube kann hier vermutlich einfach sagen, das ist ein Video, das ist eine Werbung und das beim selben Skript, das im Hintergrund läuft.
Das kann jederzeit einfach geändert werden und so können sich die einzelnen Skripte auch mal überlagern und man blockiert aus Versehen ein Video statt einer Werbung.
Ja, neue Adblock-Folgen.
Die neue Adblock-Version kriegst du im Leben nicht so schnell.
Die musst du ja im App-Store reviewen lassen. Das heißt, du müsstest den Adblocker
dynamisch die neuesten Sachen runterladen lassen.
Von irgendeinem Service.
Wenn man gar keine Werbung sieht, kann es sein, dass man sogar ausgeloggt wird, manchmal zumindest und YouTube kann natürlich auch die Frequenz
massiv erhöhen. Zweimal am Tag kann der Anfang sein, wir können aber auch bei zweimal pro Minute liegen und dann wird es für die Leute, die die Filterlisten,
bei Adblockern pflegen, ein unfassbarer Mehraufwand, das alles zu betreiben.
Bedenkt man dann noch, dass die Videos auf der Webseite nur dann laden, nachdem eine Werbung gesehen wurde,
dann kann das ein sehr schnelles Aus für viele Adblocker bedeuten.
Dahinter steckt natürlich die Idee, YouTube Premium zu etablieren und ja, ich habe das selbst schon seit einigen Jahren.
Da ich kein Spotify habe und nur YouTube Music, ist es mir das allemal wert. Es hört sich zwar nach einem fairen Modell an, das sowohl uns Creator als auch YouTube-Mitgliedern,
es hört sich zwar nach einem fairen Modell an, das sowohl uns Creator als auch YouTube-Mitgliedern, es hört sich zwar nach einem fairen Modell an, das sowohl uns Creator als auch YouTube-Mitgliedern,
als auch eure Zeit bedenkt, aber ich persönlich finde es ziemlich schade, wenn Menschen, die sich kein Premium leisten wollen oder können, zugeballert werden mit Werbung.
Zumal das am Ende echt viele Seiten wären, für die man ein Premium bräuchte.
Und ich erschrecke jedes Mal, wenn ich woanders YouTube schaue, wie unfassbar viel Werbung eigentlich kommt.
Auf der anderen Seite, vielleicht wird ja dann die Frequenz und Menge an Werbung wieder etwas reduziert, wenn eigentlich mehr Leute im Durchschnitt Werbung sehen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Aber es gibt ein Thema...
Ein Thema, das wir noch nicht betrachtet haben, das sind Google Ads.
Wenn YouTube mit diesem Modell Erfolg hat, dann liegt natürlich nahe, dass man das auf Google Ads ausweitet, so ein Update eben.
Sozusagen eine Werbung, die sie nicht ablehnen.
Also, wenn es wirklich advanced wird und irgendwann mal sogar die Werbung encoded wird in den Videostream,
was schwierig ist, wie gesagt, das erzeugt ja auch unglaublichen Rechenaufwand auf Anbieterseite,
dann sind sogar in gedownloadeten Videos Werbung.
Und das auf jeder Webseite.
Das finde ich ziemlich furchtbar, denn mit all den Push-Benachrichtigungen erlauben Newsletter,
Registrierungsangeboten und Ads, die einfach mitten ins Gesicht reinpoppen, sind die meisten Blogs und Nachrichten-Websites einfach nicht mehr benutzbar.
Das stimmt.
Und im Gegensatz zu YouTube Premium gibt es kein solches Programm für Google Ads.
Aber es ist auch deutlich schwieriger, das Ganze mit Google Ads durchzuführen, denn irgendwo auf der Webseite müssen die Ads ja angezeigt werden.
Bei YouTube ist der Verteiler der Ads derselbe wie der Anbieter der Videos.
Dadurch ist dieses Mischverhältnis einfach sehr viel leichter.
Eine Nachrichten-Webseite muss irgendwo auf der Webseite einen gewissen Bereich reservieren
und sie müssen die Werbung von extern, also von einem anderen Anbieter, als ihren restlichen Inhalt nachladen.
Dieser für Werbung reservierte Bereich, der kann ja relativ easy blockiert werden, das hatten wir ja schon.
Und die externe Domain, wo die Werbung dann auch noch nicht auf den Weg kommt, ist dann auch nicht so einfach.
wenn der bereich blockiert ist könnte euch die website rauswerfen gut bleibt domain blockieren
sprich nicht einfach von google apps irgendwas laden und hier wird jetzt noch mal ein wenig
lustig denn google apps ist ausschließlich im frontend eurer webseite aktiv heißt wenn ich
auf meiner webseite von google integrieren dann macht mein server wo also die website liegt nichts
mit der werbung selbst ihr kommt nicht von meinem server kennt die tatsächliche werbung die ihr dann
seht nicht mal man bindet einfach nur ein skript ein und das skript lädt dann die werbung direkt
von eurem browser aus deswegen ist das so leicht zu blockieren auch macht man nun was man bei
youtube tut sprich man wechselt ständig das skript dann müsste man das ganze serverseitig machen ich
als entwickler der website habe also plötzlich mehrere skripte beziehungsweise sogar einen
algoritm
muss die euch die werbung dann anzeigen das heißt ich liefere euch im besten fall die werbung und
nicht mehr google direkt die werbung wird von google an meinen server geladen und mein server
zeigt euch dann direkt die werbung an nicht mehr google dadurch wird das blockieren zwar schwerer
aber das heißt jetzt wird es aber echt pfeifert also da hätte ich gar keinen bock drauf das sorgt
das sorgt ja da und dann muss ja mein backend mehr machen ist auch dass nicht
mehr google eure daten sammelt und sagt zu welchem thema er jetzt werbung bekommt sondern ich
müsste das direkt tun und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich gut denn aktuell sammeln werbe
treiben überall daten massig und massiv ich bin zb auf eон p길 krieg auf einer völlig anderen
website dann aber die werbung für ich sehe keine kleidung stücken ohne das hatte ich auch schon
öfters wo ich mir gedacht haben wir wissen die das sei noch überall werbung für ähnliche kleidung das
geht aber nur sein dass er natürlich partiderschасть der noises wegen habe finde ich dazeit ja wenn dann
Geht aber nur, weil Google entscheidet, welche Werbung wir sehen, nicht der Website-Betreiber.
Denn Google hat durch Tracking die Information, was ihr überall euch ansehen wollt und angesehen habt.
Wechseln wir zu dieser etwas schwereren, zu blockierenden Art von Werbung, dann entscheidet der Betreiber der Website.
Und der hat wahrscheinlich nicht die Information, welche Techwear-Hose ich mir vorgestern angesehen habe.
Das heißt, Werbung wechselt von personalisiert, vielleicht, wenn wir Glück haben, zu kontextbasiert.
Wenn ich einen Artikel zu Techwear-Fashion lese, kriege ich Techwear-Werbung.
Wenn ich einen Artikel zu AI lese, kriege ich Werbung.
Ich glaube sogar, ehrlich gesagt, dass personalisierte Werbung, ich glaube sogar, die meisten 0815-User finden das gut.
Eine AI-App. Und das wiederum würde heißen, vielleicht zumindest, Google sammelt...
Da kriege ich ja endlich das empfohlen, was mich auch interessiert. Ja, das ist ja gerade der Sinn davon.
Gekauft hättest du dir es sonst nicht, aber...
Vielleicht weniger Daten über mich.
Und ehrlich gesagt, würde mich das ziemlich glücklich machen.
Ja, vielleicht sieht man dann mehr Werbung, aber vielleicht drehen dann alle auch wieder eine Stufe runter,
wenn die Einnahmen insgesamt gestiegen sind.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Weil eben nicht mehr so viele exportiert werden.
Weniger dafür kontextbezogene Werbung.
Damit könnte ich ehrlich gesagt sogar leben.
Und im Zweifel gibt es ja für Seiten, die man viel nutzt, immer noch Premium.
An der Stelle vielleicht eine kurze Frage in die Runde.
Ich habe überlegt, für unsere Bootstrap Academy als Option zu geben, Videos ohne YouTube zu schauen.
Also aktuell sind die meisten ja von YouTube.
Ich habe eingebettet und ich würde sie eigentlich ganz gerne nativ integrieren.
Ich habe ja die Videodateien.
Oh, Chat, ich glaube, wir sollten denen das Wubblos Videoarchiv verkaufen.
Auch zum Beispiel, wenn das bei den Hacking-Videos schon der Fall ist.
Das ginge allerdings...
Inklusive AI-Transcribing.
...Zahlung, weil Serverkosten.
Der Speicherplatz würde ja drastisch steigen, wenn ich das für jedes Video mache.
Wäre das für euch eine Option oder würdet ihr dann tatsächlich lieber die YouTube-Videos schauen wollen?
Schreibt mir das ganz gerne mal.
Danke und bis Donnerstag.
Ja, gutes Video.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Sehr nice.
Nice.
Leute, ich habe übertrieben.
Hunger, ich gehe jetzt fürs Essen.
Was macht ein Fachinformatiker für System...
Alter, der ist ja mal super, super Business, keck, keck Business, Alter.
Ne, der nicht.
Der sieht auch nicht so keck Business aus.
Auf dem Thumbnail sieht er mega keck Business aus.
Mit dem anderen.
Anzug.
Hier, Leute.
Jetzt wird's Zeit.
P-Pro-Fat-Time.
Ja.
Nudeln mit Lachs, korrekt.
Okay, Leute.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
C-U.